[Musique]
Hubert Vedrine bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement vous m'avez déjà invité
donc on me connaît un peu
j'ai passé 19 ans dans le cœur du
pouvoir c'est-à-dire les 14 années avec
François mitteran à l'Élysée comme
conseil diplomatique porte-parole
conseiller pour les affaires
stratégiques Secrétaire Général puis 5
années à la tête du ministère des
Affaires étrangères le le K d'oré dans
la cohabitation Chirac Jospin et donc
dans les 19 années que j'ai passé non
pas dans la politique mais au pouvoir la
distinction est importante j'ai connu
les trois
cohabitations après j'ai préféré mener
une vie plus libre plus indépendante en
enseignant en voyageant en consultant
mant conseil plutôt et en faisant des
des livres et des conférences mais je
garde un intérêt énorme qui un intérêt
de toute ma vie pour les questions
internationales notamment on a décidé de
vous faire revenir aujourd'hui pour
parler géopolitique pensé stratégique et
tout plein d'autres sujets inhérents et
connectés intriqués avec ces ces sujets
chauds je voudrais qu'on aborde le
problème de la guerre
russo-ukrainienne comment pourquoi
comment on en est arrivé là est-ce que
c'est un manque de socioperception
est-ce que c'est un manque de
renseignement est-ce que c'est un manque
de discernement est-ce que c'est un
manque de je dirais de de
maturité de perception de la montée de
ce
conflit moi je dirais qu'on ne peut pas
l'analyser et ne pas pas anticiper les
suites notamment si on ne revient pas en
arrière
jusqu'à la fin de l'URS la vraie date
importante dans cette partie du monde
dans l'histoire contemporaine c'est pas
la chute du mur entre guillemets qui
était une ouverture d' c'est la fin de
l'Union soviétique fin 91 l'URS
disparaît parce que il a le signe pour
la Russie puis les futur dirigeants de
Biélorussie d'Ukraine Kazakhstan se
mettent d'accord pour dire qu'il y a
plus d'Urs tant qu'il y a plus de
président de l'URS et disent à
Gorbatchev tu t'en va puis qu'il y a
plus de plus Deon donc il faut revenir à
ça parce que dans la première période
près on la Russie à nouveau la Russie
entre autres à partir de 92 et je pense
moi comme pensait les les vieux
responsables américains de l'époque de
la guerre froide qui avaient combattu
l'Union soviétique toute leur vie mais
qui pensaient qu'il fallait penser la
suite aménager la suite gérer la suite
et pas simplement dire on a gagné
terminé et on s'en fiche totalement de
ce qui va passer en Russie ailleurs donc
je suis de l'école réaliste non pas par
idéologie réaliste mais parce que j'ai
passé ma ma vie dans la la
réalité l'école du réalisme c'est
l'école du bon sens c'est l'école de
quoi c'est l'école de quand vous vivez
dans la réalité vous pouvait pas avoir
des visions
gémériqu complètement abstrait ou
idéologique donc j'ai vécu ça et je
pense qu'ils avaient raison en disant
qu'il fallait organiser les choses et
notamment s'occuper de la question
ukrainienne non résolue mais je parle
pas d' y a 2 ans il faut bien distinguer
dans les les les 30 années donc l'idée
de brginski notamment qui avait été le
conseiller du président Carter que les
gens oublient mais brenssk joue un rôle
considérable à l'époque parce que c'est
lui qui avait eu l'idée de de faire
financé par l'Arabie les l'islamiste en
Afghanistan pour faire sortir les Russes
avec des conséquences géantes qui navait
pas mesurer celui qui avait théorisé le
fait que pour que la Russie ne
redevienne jamais un empire dangereux il
fallait distinguer dissocier l'Ukraine
et la Russie quelle que soit la la
complexité l'obscurité de l'histoire ce
mais le même brigetski considérait
qu'après il fallait non pas que
l'Ukraine soit dans un camp ou dans
l'autre mais qu'elle soit autonome avec
un statut de neutralité gen la Finlande
pendant la guerre froide qui s'en est
très bien porté d'ailleurs donc il avait
imaginé un plan dans lequel il y aurait
eu neutralisation de l'Ukraine garantie
garantie militaire de deux côtés
l'Ukraine n'étant pas dans une alliance
il était contre l'entrée de l'Ukraine
dans le temps alors qu'il avait combattu
toute sa vie contre l'URS voyez la chtit
la pensée il pensait qu'il fallait
statut spécial pour la Crimée
internationale et un statut spécial une
autonomie pour le donbas bon ce plan n'a
pas échoué par qu'il n'a jamais été
tenté donc dans les années après la
guerre après la la fin de l'URS plutôt
dans les 10 12 années après les
États-Unis se disent on a gagné terminé
c'est la fin de l'histoire on a gagné
donc on va pas se préoccuper de ce que
pensent tous ces petits peuples partout
ça nous intéresse pas il y a déjà l'idée
qui exprimera ob plus tard qui est que
la Russie n'est de vu qu'une puissance
régionale avec une capacité dans le
voisinage donc c'est pas assez important
pour s'en occuper donc il y a plusieurs
il y a toute une décennie où il aurait
fallu faire ce que disait Kissinger
lui-même qui était rival de brigenski
mais là-dessus il se rejoignait il a
longtemps dit c'est une erreur de ne pas
avoir intégré la Russie la nouvelle
Russie dans un ensemble de sécurité en
Europe c'est réclamer Poutine ou pas pas
du tout non mais c'est avant après avant
on est sous yelsine pas du tout par
amamour de la Russie hein encore moins
de Poutine mais parce que c'est pour des
raisons de sécurité en Europe c'était
plus intelligent c'est ce que
pensaittiran d'illeur puisquil l'avait
dit mais beaucoup beaucoup trop tôt donc
les gens n'avaient pas compris le 30 31
décembre 89 avec surordidé de
Confédération donc ça n'a pas eu lieu il
y a eu finalement donc l'élargissement
de l' temps enfin toute une période et
donc je fais avant de répondre à votre
question sur l'Ukraine aujourd'hui je
fais parti des gens qui pensent que les
États-Unis notamment ont raté l'occasion
pendant donc 10 à 12 années d'Ant que le
problème apparaissait déjà parce que dès
le début yelsin président de la Russie
avait obtenu un traité euh d'accord et
d'amitié de coopération avec l'Ukraine
il avait fait mettre que les Russes la
Russie avait un droit de regard sur les
Russes à l'extérieur les russophones
parce que eux voient comme des Russes
donc y compris dans le donbas après il y
a d'autres endroits donc c'est pas
Poutine c'est même avant Poutine donc il
aurait fallu que l'Occident si
l'Occident av était
moins triomphant moins ivre de sa
victoire en fait arrogant c'est en tout
cas c'est perçu comme ça par les autres
ça dis il y a un problème à régler c'est
pas il y a pas que là où l'Occident a a
dérapé par arrogance et miopi en tout
cas c'est votre question sur l'Ukraine
donc en résumé je pense que pendant 10 à
15 ans il y a beaucoup d'occasions
manqué sur yelsine Poutine 1 Poutine 2
medvedef après le le même Poutine qui
pendant des années disait aux
Occidentaux je veux coopérer avec vous
il avait d'ailleurs soutenu l'Amérique
au moment du 11 septembre au moment de
l'attaque le même Poutine qui demandait
à tous les grands chefs d'entreprises
mondiaux occidentaux de venir en Russie
d'investir d'apporter les technologies
au bout d'un moment ça ça bascule et
puis ça devient le Poutine
d'après qui dit terminer l'Occident est
un ennemi et qui réveille la toute une
espèce de machine un peu paranoïaque ou
commment on veut disant la Russie contre
l'Occident qui est en circlé par par
l'Occident ce qui fait rigoler quand on
voit la carte parce que la la Russie est
comme ça mais elle se sent quand même
encerclé donc je pense ça sur les
occasion manqué l'Occident n'a pas été
stratège pas du tout mais là c'est
vraiment les États-Unis parfois il y a
des erreurs européennes et là c'est Plô
américain et l'Occident n'a pas été
dissuasif après parce que dès lors qu'on
avait raté la première période il est
évident qu'il
fallait dissuader la Russie de Poutine
comp tenu de l'évolution de toute
toute tentative ce qui aboutit à la
guerre en Ukraine ça c'est l'histoire
longue longue après dans la période tout
à fait récente ce qui est frappant c'est
que personne personne même pas Zelinski
ni les Américains croyaent à l'attaque
russe comment ça se fait ça les
informations recueillies par les
services américains montré qu'il y avait
des mouvements de troupes des
concentrations des trucs mais quand le
chef d'étatmajor américain général M le
disait à la Maison Blanche oui je sais
mais il y en a tout le temps
il y a tout le temps des mouvements
comme ça donc ça veut rien dire et puis
il ne fera pas le l'erreur monumentale
d'attaquer là c'est complètement absurd
C il logique parce que en fait aucun de
ces gens ne prennent Poutine pour un fou
ça c'est une interprétation occidentale
auou centrée après donc ils ont pas vu
mais après en même temps quand Poutine
attaque les américains pensaient pas que
l'Ukraine puisse résister puisqu'ils ont
proposé à Zelinski de l'exfiltrer en
Pologne tout de suite bon donc c'est un
enchaînement tout à fait étrange mais
l'élément
arrogance américaine donc un peu
occidentale pas la France qui conduit à
l'aveuglement c'est quand même un fil
conducteur bon alors après les choses
s'engagent et là on voit que Poutine a
fait plusieurs erreurs d'analyse géante
il a vraiment cru comptenu des
informations qu'on lui donne autour de
lui qu'on connaît pas queil allait
gagner en 48 he que mettre la main sur
l'Ukraine avec une propagande totalement
débile sur la dénasification mais
peut-être qu'il y croit lui-même on nen
sait rien en tout cas il croyait que
militairement il allait prendre KF et
tout le reste ou au minimum
neutraliser tout le système ukrainien
les les bases militaires les aéroports
et cetera pour contrôler l'ensemble du
pays ça n'a pas marché du tout il a une
résistance inattendue même les
Ukrainiens ont été presque surpris de
leur capacité ils avaient été quand même
formés avant il y avait des formate sur
place depuis 2014 ils étaient formés ils
avaient des liens très étroits avec les
États-Unis des bases de la CIA euh mais
il a il y a plusieurs il y a deux
politiques américaines il y avait une
politique et celle des présidents en
gros il y a aucun président américain
qui a vu que dans même quand ils ont vu
que ils avaient raté l'occasion avec
Poutine et que Poutine était dur à mon
avis aucun président américain n'a
préparé une provocation exprès je crois
pas je peux pas le prouver mais je crois
pas mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des
groupes aux États-Unis une partie du
département d'État euh des personnes
formées par Madeline Albright par
exemple comme Madame newand des gens
comme ça qui jouaient un peu ça et on
connaît que on sait que le système
américain est très sensible à ce qu'on
appelle la bas les lobis son son
complexe que tout le monde s'en réclame
toute la journée il y avait donc des des
groupes liés aux Polonais aux Ukrainiens
aux baltes qui voulaient pas simplement
préserver l'Ukraine mais en faire un peu
un fier de lance un élément de
provocation mais on peut moi je peux pas
dire moi que c'était la politique
américaine parce qu'en réalité Nuland
sur place oui Nuland peut-être mais pas
les président parce que les présidents
américains il peut y avoir plusieurs
étages hein il peut y avoir des nuances
y compris dans d'autres pays mais depuis
on va dire Obama ils se disent le
problème numéro 1 c'est la Chine c'est
la Chine Obama avait décrété le pivot
pivote vers la Chine il est tellement
sophistiqué que les gens comprenaient
pas toujours ce qu'il disait mais en fa
c'était clair Trump il a fait se c'est
gros sabot et Biden a continué problème
numéro 1 c'est la Chine donc aucun des
président était obsédé par le fait de
transformer l'Ukraine en une machine de
provocation sur la Russie mais je pense
qu'il y a eu dans le système américain
un peu occidental après des groupes qui
jouaient ça par rapport à ça bon voyez
je répond entre les deux mais ça
n'expliqueable pourquoi Poutine a
attaqué en prenant un risque phénoménal
d'échec avec énormément de de morts de
dégâts surtout le risque de déclasser la
Russie pour très longtemps
de remettre la Russie dans la main de la
Chine qui est quand même une une
angoisse de beaucoup de Russes alors
évidment il peut se dire à la longue je
gagnerai parce que
l'Occident il a vu l'Occident comme
beaucoup plus affaibli et divisé qu'il
nait il a cru que l'Occident qui est à
son avis complètement décadent pour 36
raisons sociétales allait s'effondrer
donc il s'est trompé làdessus même si au
moment où nous parlons il y a une
inquiétude sur la capacité
militaire de l'armée ukrainienne pour
résister donc voilà une sorte de
panorama général de ce qui s'est passé
mais c'est clair que Poutine s'attendait
pas en attaquant à réveiller l'esprit de
défense dans toute l'Europe dans
l'alliance il n' pas créé la défense
européenne il a réveillé l'esprit de
défense dans l'Europe du coup
l'Allemagne renonce à sa son pacifisme
en fait depuis longtemps l'Allemagne n'
a plus d'armée en fait d'ailleurs quand
quand la France a eu besoin un Tor Ron
BR cell d'avoir des des Allemands c'est
des Allemands qui faisaient rien qui
sortaient pas du du baraquement qui
s'arrêit de travailler à 17h bon il av
plus d'armée allemande maintenant il se
projetteent deux divisions de tank en
Lituanie deux divisions de tank en
Lituanie oui maintenant récemment mais
je parlais dans la durée donc Poutine a
réveillé l'esprit de défense chez tous
les Européens d'ailleurs les neutres
rejoignent l'OTAN donc une partie des
déclarations très dures des des
Scandinaves c'est pour justifier par
rapport à l'EUR opinion le fait d'aller
dans l' tempan contrairement à une
tradition on va dire neutraliste et mais
c'est l'alliance c'est pas la défense
européenne là on en parlera peut-être
mais il y a il y a une différence
d'approche entre le discours français et
le discours des autres européens en tout
cas il s'attendait pas à ça et
d'ailleurs l'an dernier vous rappelez
que l'idée générale c'était plutôt que
les Ukrainiens allaient réussir à
reconquérir le donbas complètement
jusqu'à la frontière et on voyait qu'aux
États-Unis donc toujours centré sur la
Chine
il se disait jusqu'où on les soutient et
le chef d'étatmajor américain que j'ai
déjà mentionné tout à l'heure n'était
pas pour ilons soutenir l'Ukraine dans
l'attaque sur la Crimée donbas peut-être
Crimée non mais de toute façon la
question s'est pas posée puisqu'on est
dans l'inverse et maintenant la question
qui se pose c'est est-ce que l'armée
ukrainienne telle qu'elle est est
capable de résister à l'avancée russe
qui avance pas en galopant mais qui gr
je rappelle que la ligne occidentale
fixée par Biden depuis le début que moi
j'approuve d's c'est de dire on
empêchera Poutine de gagner en Ukraine
pe pas le laisser gagner la bataille
d'Ukraine c'est trop dangereux mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pas le
laisser gagner ça veut dire le le bouter
en dehors des frontières ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire d'abord bloquer
l'attaque bloquer l'attaque c'est veut
dire qu'il faut que l'armée ukrainienne
ne s'effondre pas d'ù le débat sur
comment faut-il la renforcer en ce
moment ça veut dire après on sait pas
très bien que avons du rapport de force
globale qui est président aux États-Unis
ça veut dire que au minimum
euh le la la bataille s'arrête au
minimum que si possible les Russes sont
obligés de ressortir du donbas la Crimée
c'est encore autre chose mais disons
l'élément clé c'est de stopper ce qui
est maintenant l'avancée russe on n'est
pas dans l'hypothèse de l'avancée
ukrainienne en tout cas il y a une
distinction entre empêcher Poutine de
gagner avec on peut discuter ce que ça
veut dire et d'autre part être pris dans
l'engrenage de la guerre à la Russie et
ça Biden a dit non depuis le début les
Américains redisent ça sans arrêt même
lincol et cetera or il y a une partie
des européens ou des médias en Europe
qui jouent plutôt ça qui sont pour dire
il faut aller plus loin on n pas peur de
Poutine il essaie de nous faire peurve
ses armes nucléaires mais on n' pas peur
même pas peur donc on est prêt à aller
au-delà donc il y a un courant quand
même
d'opinion en Europe mais les Américains
n'ont pas bougé par rapport à ça
d'ailleurs dans l'épisode récent il ils
ont rappelé
que les Ukrainiens ne demandaient pas
d'homme au sol que c'était hors de
question mais la question se pose de
fournir des avions et des missiles donc
on en est là et finalement la ligne
occidentale en dépit des différences
voire divergences entre allier elle a
pas bougé empêcher Poutine de gagner
c'estàd stopper l'avancée alors après ça
débouche sur plusieurs scénarios qui
sont alors il y a le scénario où la la
Russie avance quand même c'est possible
on bien on entend le discours sur les
faiblesses de l'armée Ukraine parce que
ce pays est quand même marisé sur le
plan des des pertes humaines des
souffrances puis manque d'armes manque
de munition et cetera ils ont besoin des
informations américaines en plus pour
mener la bataille moi il me semble que
l'Amérique peut pas laisser Poutine
gagner une bataille d'Ukraine mettre la
main sur odessin par exemple la forcerie
sur Kief pourquoi je dis ça j'ai pas
d'information secrète je suis pas je
suis pas en fonction en ce moment si les
Américains n'arrivent pas à le bloquer
tout ce que disent les Américains
ailleurs et notamment face à la Chine
s'effondre ils n'ont plus de crédibilité
donc le système américain Biden ou pas
Biden il est obligé de réagir ça veut
dire fournir des avions des F16
aux Ukrainiens alors soit directement
soit pas l'intermédiaire de Pays-Bas ou
autre et puis alors il y a le missile
allemand le torus que le chancelier veut
pas donner chancelier SCHS parce que
l'Allemagne reste en fait pacifiste
fondamentalement et ils disent on peut
pas le donner parce que ça ne fonctionne
pas s'il y a pas des des techniciens
allemands autour à mon avis il sera
obligé de bouger sur les missiles mais
pas sur les hommes au seul donc on en
est là dans un moment délicat où il y a
donc l'hypothèse où quand même
la Russie avance beaucoup et donc quand
même l'Occident doit surmonter le
blocage du programme américain au
Congrès et renforcer l'armée ukrainienne
dans sa défense après l'autre hypothèse
j'ai dit que n'est plus prise en compte
la victoire ukrainienne massive donc
vous avez l'hypothèse de l'enlisement à
un moment l'arrêt des combat l'arrê des
combats alors soit dans le courant de
l'année soit parce que Trump arrive a
été je sais pas siil sera élu mais c'est
une hypothèse il faut noter qu'elle est
déjà dans toutes les têtes l'élection
américaine c'est toujours très important
mais c'est important après on se dit si
un tel est élu voilà ce qui va se passer
mais là beaucoup de gens dans le monde
ont intégré ça et certains jouent le
retour de Trump ou le craignent Poutine
il attend Trump zinski a peur du retour
de Trump Nanou ailleurs il attend il
attend Trump voyez donc ça joue déjà un
rôle maintenant on reparle un peu plus
tard dans cette
interview ou on peut reparler sur
l'Ukraine ou oui oui on continue
l'Ukraine pour revenir à la stratégie au
plan diplomatique quand Emmanuel Macron
dit on va envoyer des hommes sur place
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire c'est la
dissuasion c'est
l'ambiguité comment il avait formulé ça
l'ambiguité stratégique oui alors je
suis pas le porte-parole du président
mais je peux ESS avec vous de d'analyser
cette épisode mais depuis le début la
France est quand même dans le l'ensemble
occidental sur la même ligne il faut
empêcher Poutine de gagner en Ukraine
sans être dans l'engrenage de la guerre
il y a pas de vraie différence au fond
après il y a des débats sur quels sont
les pays qui aide le plus ça dépend
alors dans le cas du président par
rapport à votre question d'après ce que
je comprends il a le sentiment que les
Européens ne se rendent pas compte de la
gravité des
choses en Ukraine et
après après ça veut dire si Trump est
élu et si Trump non seulement est élu
mais applique son programme c'est pas
évident hein il peut être élu et faire
tout à fait autre chose vu ce vu ce
qu'il est bon donc le président Macron
si je comprends bien ce qu'on m'a
expliqué il veut il voulait lancier un
électrochoc en fait donc pas forcément
envoyer des gens mais lancier un
électrochoc c'est tellement grave qu'on
peut rien écarter pour que les gens se
disent mais mon dieu où est-ce qu'on est
qu'est-ce qui se passe tout ça en
espérant que une fois passé la
l'agitation des réactions émotives en
réaction les V se dire c'est vraiment
grave qu'est-ce qu'on fait peut-être
tout simplement revenir à la ligne
annoncé depuis le début empêcher Poutine
de gagner la bataille en Ukraine ça veut
dire fournir plus
mais on peut je sais pas si c'est la la
vraie explication mais je dire ça un
certain sens c'est vu comme ça sauf
qu'il faut compléter la la plupart des
commentaires en disons que ça concerne
l'alliance ça concerne pas spécialement
les Européens parce que les Ukrainiens
je répète ils veulent les avions
américain ils veul de l'argent américain
ils veulent les missilees allemand donc
c'est pas une question France-Russie
c'est même pas une question Europe
Russie c'est une question alliance
Russie donc je ne sais pas si le ce qu'a
dit le président donc pour ce quel
cogotier je redis lancer un
électrochoc est-ce que ça va conduire à
une position de l'Alliance tout entière
plus plus plus plus ferme on le verra au
sommet de l'OTAN parce que il y a un
sommet à la mi-juillet je crois aux
États-Unis pour le 75e anniversaire de
l'OTAN et il faut bien que les Alliés se
présentent de façon ilons convergente
cohérente donc dès maintenant il doent
être en train de travailler sur
l'attitude à adopter là parce qu'on peut
pas imaginer aujourd'hui que les
Européens à eux seuls même pour des gens
qui seraient heureux c'est mon cas qui y
a un jour une Europe puissance une une
capacité militaire européenne c'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui c'est n pas le cas il
y a des pays en Europe qui ont la
capacité mais pas globalement donc on
peut pas faire la pass aujourd'hui sur
la la capacité américaine qui est
déterminante mais on tombe sur le
blocage du programme de Biden au Congrès
pour aider à nouveau l'Ukraine
75 euh 75 milliards je crois et euh donc
un programme énorme faudra vérifier le
chiffre mais qui est bloqué par les
trumpistes qui prennent ça en otage en
disant si vous ne durcissez pas votre
politique sur la la frontière sud
immigration Mexique on vote pas bon mon
pronostic c'est que la pression
migratoire est tellement
géante c'est c'est vrai en Europe aussi
mais on en parlera que Biden va être
obligé de bouger là-dessus parce que
même les même les latinau comme on dit
là-bas aux États-Unis devenu américains
électeurs américain du Parti démocrate
ils veulent que ce soit mieux régulé ils
ont toujours des cousins à faire venir
mais ils veulent pas que n'importe qui
puisse venir n'importe comment même les
démocrates donc je pense qu'il va être
obligé de bouger donc moi je n'exclus
pas que que la nouvelle de l'Ukraine
soit votée finalement donc il y aurait
un il y aurait une alliance cohérente
plus dissuasive
ell son là e se dirait
bon je peux plus tellement avancer mais
j'attends Trump donc ça nous renvoie à
l'hypothèse Trump quand quand Emmanuel
Macron fait une vidéo sur sur TikTok et
sur les réseaux sociaux pour dire il
faut aider l'Ukraine il faut aider
l'Ukraine il faut aider l'Ukraine parce
que aussi en fin de vidéo il dit la
France a des intérêts stratégiques en
Ukraine pour des questions de
ressources quand vous entendez ça est-ce
que vous pensez que la France a des
intérêts stratégiques en terme de
ressources en Ukraine est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu'il y a aussi un un une un
2uxè prisme de lecture sur des questions
économique de transformation de matières
premières dans le sol ukrainien pour les
économies euh thermo-industrialisées
européennes et le prisme de lecture
poutinien qui dit euh après l'Ukraine
ils veulent se faire la Russie et couper
la Russie en morceau pour sa'acaparer
les ressources ça fait partie de la
propagande poutinienne ou ça peut être
envisager pour des questions purement
basiques alors vous pouvez g dans les
deux sens hein bien entendu toujours h
en sachant en sachant que la Russie a
quand même énormément de territoire
énormément de ressources déjà bien sûr
mais pour des questions de contrôle du
marché du blé contrôle de certaines
terres rares ça peut être intéressant
aussi mais le comment dire sur
l'économie mondiale je sais bien que ça
rentre en ligne de compte mais je dirais
pas c'est la raison
cachée moi je suis pas du tout je suis
pas complotiste de tempérament donc
c'est pas c'est pas une question d'être
complotiste je dis pas je parle pas à
vous je par en général mais il y a il y
a plein de conflit au 20e siècle les Les
gros malins disaient oui je sais c'est
le pétrole même quand il y avait aucun
pétrole dans l'affaire voyez il y a
toujours l'idée qu'il y a une une
explication cachée alors dire que les
États ont des intérêts oui c'est évident
ça y compris économique et dire envillir
l'IRAC pour apporter la démocratie et
les écoles pour les petites filles c'est
enoreutre chose ça démocratie c'est un
autre sujet ça et la question des
intérêts oui ça joue on a intérêt
globalement mais il y a pas que la
France c'est un commentaire européen on
aurait intérêt une Ukraine qui
fonctionne la guerre qui s'arrête
l'Ukraine se reconstruit si possible
entièrement mais en tout cas toute
l'Ukraine qui moins le donbas si
malheureusement c'est passelum autrement
et on a intérêt à ce qu'il a un pays qui
qui se développe qui qui échange qui
exporte C céréales bon il y a un intérêt
collectif estce que ça marche bien bon
après il y a la question énergétique
mais le choc est déjà absorbé en matière
de question énergétique et il concerne
beaucoup plus l'Allemagne que nous mais
comme pour l'Allemagne c'est très
compliqué de se passer du gaz russe bon
marché tout le monde les avait encouragé
hein à commencer par les Américains et
de se passer des marchés chinois parce
qu'il y a d'autres problèmes en Chine
vous voyez bien que là l'économie
allemande ralenti il y a une
répercussion sur nous donc la remarque
du président est très juste
indirectement on ve dire c'est très bien
indir mais je dis pas que c'est la cause
principale parce qu'enit fait les uns et
les autres mis à part le calcul de
Poutine qui est un peu difficile à
comprendre navit pas du tout du tout
intéresst que ça arrive même pas les
États-Unis par rapport aux gens qui
disent oui c'est les États-Unis qui en
profitent ils ont ils ont rien fait pour
je parle des présidents à nouveau les
dirigeants américains ils ont rien fait
pour ça certains lobby oui donc
l'affaire des intérêts oui ça joue un
rôle ça joue un rôle mais c'est pas
l'explication majeur bon et on sens
inverse du point de vue russe euh ce que
veulent les Russes c'est quand
même garder le
l'essence contrôle de moins la moitié de
la mer
Noire pour pouvoir à partir de la crmée
ou ailleurs avoir leurs propres
exportations dans l'idéal ils voulait
boucler toute la mer noir mais il sont
pas arrivés les Ukrainiens ont réussi à
développer des stratégies notamment à
base de drone ils ont
rétabli disons des couloirs les
corridors à peu près SEF quoi pour
sortir les choses donc on VO bien que ça
joue
mais je le vois pas comme ayant été le
déclencheur ni l'élément de la solution
alors il faudrait se projeter dans un
long long terme où tout ça aurait été
terminé dépassé et on commencera à se
dire plutôt d'ailleurs les Américains
que nous les Européens puisqu'on est un
peu binaire sur ce sujets se dire bon
comment finalement on organise la
coexist par qu'il y a toujours la Russie
à côté est toujours là malgré tout mais
c'est une question pour après PRS demain
ça pas tout de suite comment vous
expliquez que
maintenant le ministre des Affaires
étrangères français Stéphane séjourné
disent bon maintenant ça sert plus à
rien de discuter avec les
Russes en diplomatie ça se dit ça bah il
y a des moments où ça se dit oui mais
pas tout le temps la diplomatie c'est
l'inverse normalement on a inventé la
diplomatie à la Renaissance entre des
cités état rival pour qu'il a un autre
instrument que la guerre donc
normalement on parle avec les gens qui
vous menacent on parle pas avec des amis
ça sert à rien on parle avec des
adversaires des gens qui vous ment mais
il y a des moments où ça sert plus à
rien donc on est sans doute dans ce
moment mais est-ce qu'il est éternel non
est-ce que après ça chauffe encore plus
non c'est pas ça c'est que aujourd'hui
parler avec Poutine sur quoi Poutine est
demandeur de rien du tout il veut garder
ce qu'il a contrôlé et avoir plus et il
attend Trump tout il attend l'élection
américaine est-ce que est-ce que il
attend att je continue à répondre à gens
donc parler je sais pas qui parle
d'ailleurs qui parlerait parler avec
Poutine avant l'élection américaine
c'est une perte de temps c'est pas un
scandale
monumental dans l'histoire en fait on a
parlé avec des gens dont on avait dit
1000 fois qu'on parlerait jamais avec
eux ceci cela bon donc je suis un je
suis pragmatique par expérience mais là
ça sert à rien en qui n'est pas
demandeur et aucun dirigeant ukrainien
contte tenu des souffrances de l'Ukraine
ne peut parler à la Russie pour dire
quoi ils vont dire il faut il faut que
vous sortiez de l'Ukraine vous ils
éventacué la Crimée et le donbas donc il
y a pas de discussion même s'il y a eu
d'ailleurs dans la première
année après la l'attaque de Poutine pas
mal de conversations direct ou indirect
avec les
turcsomidieux plusieurs choses donc je
dirais pas qu'ils ne se parleront jamais
je peux même pas dire que tant qu'il y
aura Poutine ils se parleront jamais je
su pas sûr aujourd'hui dans le feu de
l'action tout ça est tellement choquant
horrible et puis Poutine n pas une tête
qui donne envie de parler avec lui en
plus mais on sait jamais sur après mais
dans l'hypothèse de
l'enlisement de l'arrêt des combats que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure qui pourrait pas
être suivi du tout d'une négociation en
fait encore moins d'une solution je
n'exclus pas que d'autres pays d'autres
pays disent ils peuvent pas se parler
directement mais nous on a fait un plan
quel pays la Turquie l'Arabie Saoudite
peut-être
l'Inde la Chine qui a fait un plan que
les Occidentaux ont balayé mais à
l'époqueù il pensait que l'Ukraine
allait gagner facilement il y a pas il
peut y avoir le Brésil qui voulait s'en
mêler je ne sais pas des pays africains
qui ont terriblement besoin des céréales
des uns et des autres pas les Européens
de la aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont pris
un un
parti totalement clair d'un côté donc
ils peuvent pas rentrer dans le jeu en
tout cas au début peut-être l'Amérique
aussi bizarre que ça puisse paraître
d'ailleurs on voit bien que j'ai dit que
Poutine attendait Trump mais si c'est
Biden à nouveau il peut y avoir un
moment
où Biden joue un rôle donc il reparle en
fait mais un pays comme la France
aujourd'hui n'a pas de raison n'a pas
intérêt en fait à tenter de reparler à
Poutine maintenant donc je dis oui pour
le moment mais ça n'engage pas l'avenir
à long terme on peut faire une
expérience de pensée vous a moi on peut
faire une expérience de pensée vous et
moi l'expérience de pensée suivante le
conflit chauffe encore
plus on envoie des hommes sur place on é
c belligérant et on frise la trème
guerre mondiale
thermonucléaire est-ce que vous pensez
pas que la Chine l'Arabie Saoudite deux
exemples simples vont décréter un
embargo envers les pays occidentaux pour
dire maintenant vous nous emmenez à la
trè guerre mondiale c'est mauvais pour
le business les Chinois disent pendant 3
mois on arrête de vous envoyer toutes
nos choses l'Arabie Saoudite dit pendant
3 mois on va vous mettre en sevrage
énergétique pour voir quelle réaction ça
va avoir sur le conflit c'est possible
c'est pas possible j'imagine pas ce
scénario enfin on peut pe pas je peux
pas démontrer qui qu' n'aura pas lieu
mais ça supposerait que les que
l'avancée sov russe pardon soit devenu
tel que l'ensemble de l'Alliance pas les
Européens seuls l'ensemble de l'Alliance
États-Unis en tête cons que c'est un
danger mortel pour l'Alliance et que
donc faut y aller même si l'Ukraine
n'est pas dans l' temp il y a pas
l'obligation de l'article 5 ça veut dire
entrer en guerre ça veut dire vote dans
les parlements donc ça n'aura pas lieu
en réalité enfin c'est intéressant de
voir le votre question parce que je ne
crois pas non plus que les les grands
pays du pseudo Sud global enfin on
parler et envie de ça en fait sont pas
du tout pour la guerre ça leur complique
la vie ça les embête économiquement
c'est des tas de mauvaises de mauvais
effets et en plus même dans le sud
global qui a une rhétorique globale
antioccidentale mais qui est très très
déjunie en réalité chacun même son jeu
donc chacun d'entre eux même en en
disant qu'il espère un monde po
postoccidental gère intelligemment ses
relations avec Allemagne France etgénie
et cetera donc je crois pas que le
scénario que vous avez décrit euh aura
lieu
mais on on peut pas le démontrer il y a
des il y a des surprises des
enchaînements on on on voit que la
politique américaine vise à éviter
ça depuis le début on voit énormément de
sanctions et on voit aussi énormément de
contournement de sanctions via le K
kyrgizstan on voit les
États-Unis passer par kyrgizstan on voit
l'Italie passer par kyrgizstan on voit
le commerce augmenter de 1000 % c'est
forcément que ça va en Russie est-ce
qu'il y a pas une forme d'hypocrisie des
sanctions alors il faut pour qu' a
hypocrisie faudrait qu'elle soit décidée
par des gens qui savent que ça va pas
marcher
et que ça va être contourné c'est pas le
cas tout le monde sait que ça fonctionne
pas non au début les gens qui décide les
sanctions au niveau européen ou nation
Unis enfin c'est pas le cas ou américain
ils pensent que ça va marcher il y a
beaucoup d'occidentaux qui ont pas
intégré une une évidence moi je dis
depuis 20 ou 30 ans peu importe que les
Occidentaux n'ont plus le monopole de la
puissance ils sont très très puissants
très très riches bien sûr tout le monde
vivre à l'occidental toutes les classes
moyennes du monde entier dans le sud
mais pas sous la domination des
Occidentaux mais il y a les gens qui
décident et puis les les gens qui
parlent dans les les sphères
politicomédiatiqu voyez les débats
permanents dans notre pays par exemple
les gens n'acceptent pas cette idée en
plus il a la présentation moraliste on a
une mission spéciale universelle no Bur
tout simpement donc il y a plein de gens
qui y croient énormément et il y a il y
a assez peu de gens qui disent on va
faire semblant de sanctionner ça va pas
marcher tant pis il faut faire semblant
non ça c'est très rare en fait donc je
suis plus étonné et c'est plus
préoccupant les gens qui croient que ça
va marcher et qui découvrent avec
sidération que en réalité il y a une
grande partie du monde qui joue pas le
jeu après l'attaque de Poutine qui est
une évidence quand même qui contredit
tous les élément du droit international
s'il existe bon débat aux Nations unies
à l'Assemblée génér g des Nations Unies
d'ailleurs je dis souvent pour faire
sourir que le uni est de trop les
nations sont pas Unies c'est un cadre un
forum indispensable pour parler vote 120
130 pays condamne la Russie normal
logique une quarantaine de pays
représentant les 2/ers de l'humanité les
2/ers de l'humanité en terme
démographique refus de condamner ils
sont pas du tout pour Poutine ils
détestent la guerre mais ils veulent pas
être dans le camp des Occidentaux parce
que les Occidentaux ont ça c'est un
autre débat comment ils ont réussi on n
sait rien les Européens ils ont dominé
les tr/4 du monde pendant 3 4 5 siècles
donc c'est ça la réalité du monde
d'aujourd'hui donc quand on voit ça on
peut pas s'étonner que les sanctions ne
marchent pas comme si on était les
maîtres du monde donc les Occidentaux
qui mettent ça en avant c'est en parti
pour satisfaire la partie la plus
militante de leur opinion du Parlement
ou de la presse ou des ONG ils savent
que peut-être ce sera contourné mais ils
croient quand même que ils croyaient
quand même qu'on allait pouvoir
l'imposer qu'on allait pouvoir mettre
l'économie russe à genou oui oui faut
vraiment être permettez-moi l'expression
faut vraiment être con non c'est pas une
question de connerie comme vous dites
c'est le le fait qu'on est habité par ce
que j'ai dit là il y a pas long il y a 3
minutes on a plus le monopole de la
puissance je te dis ça paraît évident en
terme d'analyse mais c'est pas du du
tout
ané les Américains les Américains il
disent non pas du tout on sera toujours
numéro 1 on empêchera la Chine
deevenenir numéro et n'importe qui
d'autre on est les numéro 1 quant aux
Européens c'est un peu différent parce
qu'ils sont plus idéalistes plus naïfs
ils disent oui mais on a dépassé les
questions de puissance ils ont dit ça
pendant 20 30 ans hein on est dans la
communauté
internationale bon moi je dis SAR il y
en a pas de communauté c'est un objectif
on n'est pas en communauté avec Poutine
ou avec les les islamistes un mot trop
chaleureux mais les Européens ils ont du
mal à intégrer ça donc l'idée de dire on
va les sanctionner c'est justifié c'est
à la fois une une réplique des
représailles une vengeance de la morale
de la puissance tout et donc beaucoup
d'entre eux sont considérer que ça
marche pas voilà mais ça ça nous montre
un monde dans lequel l'Occident va
devoir défendre absolument sa
civilisation qui est quand même à mon
avis ce qu'on a inventé de mieux bon il
y a plein de choses à corriger
euh mais sans employer tous ces procédés
qui fonctionnent
plus c'est un énorme défi pour
l'Occident enfin la f ukrainienne n'est
pas terminée mais on aura vu en tout cas
au passage que ça peut pas fonctionner
comme ça sur un sujet proche les
États-Unis il y a quelques années de
plus en plus quand même défié exaspéré
par la la montée en puissance chinoise
avait décidé de de découpler
complètement couper les relations
États-Unis Chine ils y arrivent pas ils
peuvent pas les chin non plus donc
maintenant ils disent on va
dérisquer on garde les choses mais ça
sera moins risqué ça veut dire qu'on
peut pas couper donc même chose ça nous
ramène à une formule que vous avez
employé à plusieurs reprises depuis le
début l'arrogance
occidentale qui aveugle c'est
l'arrogance occidentale ou c'est
l'arrogance de l'élite
occidentale c'est les gens qui décident
en tout cas mais les une partie des
opinion sont assez là-dessus mais après
il faut distinguer les cas où c'est
vraiment les États-Unis donc la
politique envers la Russie de 10 premiè
anné après ce sont les États-Unis sauf
le cas particulier de l'accord
d'association Union européenne Ukraine
qui avait été conçu pour couper
complètement l'Ukraine y compris l'est
de la Russie économiquement c'était
c'est une aberration complète ça c'est
européen donc il a des erreurs qui sont
pas tout à fait les mêmes selon le
moment après oui c'est les élites mais
les élites elles sont élues quand même
par des gens elles sont sont populaires
et puis a tout le système
politicomédiatique plus les réseaux en
majorité dans cette direction c'est quoi
les réseaux les réseaux sociaux j'ouvre
une petite parenthèse quel regard vous
portez sur la couverture médiatique du
conflit
russo-ukrainien est-ce que c'est
équilibré pas équilibré est-ce qu'on
voit des gens très béliqueux sur les
plateau télé est-ce que ça n'arrive
jamais dans les moments de tension ou de
guerre que les couvertures médiatiques
soi équilibré ça existe pas à aucun
moment d'ailleurs pendant la guerre de
141 quand on disait en France le
bourrage de crâne c'était le bourrage de
crâne des Allemands sur les Français et
réciproquement donc il y a aucun moment
où ce soit équilibré c'est juste
impossible en fait alors des gens en
temps de paix quand c'est cool on
négocie sans enjeu il peut y avoir des
des analyses des experts des gens très
expérimentés qui équilibrent un peu les
aire bon mais c'est pas possible on peut
parler par exemple à l'époque moderne on
peut parler de façon assez objective de
l'histoire franco-allemande on peut
c'était pas possible pendant très
longtemps France Grande-Bretagne c'était
impossible pendant des siècle bon là on
peut pas arriver à un traitement
équilibré donc vous avez la vision
occidentale avec des toutes petites
nuances la vision russe qui est
absolument sans nuance et c'est dans
d'autres pays du monde mais dans les des
journaux que personne ne lit en Europe
où les gens essaient de de faire des
analyses donc ça m'étonne pas ça
m'étonne pas c'est presque inévitable et
on peut pas empêcher que les puissances
qui s'affrontent emplo tous les procédés
de la technologie moderne c'est pas
simplement les panflés mensongers de il
y a quelques siècles donc a tous les
procédés techniques technologiques pour
pour manipuler mentir et cetera et
cetera bon c'est préoccupant que si le
moment venu ça empêche un
règlement mais avant c'est une sorte de
de mal inévitable des sociétés en en
conflit par exemple Proche Orient c'est
très c'est très gênant parce
que ça bloque les minorités courageuses
qui vudrait trouver une solution mais
sur Ukraine sur Ukraine Russie qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire simplement
que le si le conflit s'arrête qu'il faut
souhaiter pour qu' qu' plus de mort quoi
que ça s'arrête l'Europe n'est pas en
mesure de jouer un rôle après donc elle
sert obligé d'attendre que d'autres
imaginer la suite pourquoi on n'est pas
capable d'imaginer la suite pourquoi on
n'est pas capable nous Français nous la
France d'arriver de dire on connaît la
guerre on connaît la guerre en Europe on
trouve des solutions
oui mais la France au fil des années je
parle pas du président actuel du
gouvernement actuel c'est plus ancien et
est redevenu un pays occidental comme
les autres de moyen impuissance non ça
c'est autre chose parce que il y a pas
tellement de puissance dans le monde
hein il y a 200 pays où on est s jeudi
giscar il y a très longtemps eu le
courage de dire on est une puissance
moyenne hurlement contre giscar c'est
une évidence et alors moi quand j'étais
ministre pour éviter le piège j'ai une
puissance moyenne oui d'influence
mondiale donc c'est moins moins
humiliant mais il y a pas tellement de
puissance il a même pas même le G20 est
trop large j'ai a pas 20 puissances a
une quinzaine donc est encore nous avec
l'histoire géante qu'on a avec un
territoire assez petit une population
pas très nombreuses être encore une des
puissances même si plutôt les puissances
disons relativement déclinantes plutôt
que montante c'est quand même encore
énorme bon il empêche qu'en terme de
politique c'est tout le débat sur la le
gaulis le mittirandis le golomitendist
les
néoconservateurs on voit bien que depuis
maintenant assez longtemps la France
s'est banalisée enfin s'est laissée
banaliser ou s'est activement banalisée
et que donc elle n'a pas une position
particulière elle ne cherche pas en tout
cas peut-être que ça va changer
peut-être qu'à un moment donné il y aura
de nouvelles initiatives mais au jour où
vous me aujourd'hui vous me dites mais
pourquoi la France faut pas ceci cela
parce qu'elle elle a apparemment elle a
abandonné cette cette ambition là ça lui
paraît plus important aujourd'hui d'être
en pointe des pays qui mobilise l'Europe
contre la menace russe peut-être parce
que le président Macron a a espéré
pouvoir encore utilement au début ça se
défendait d' au début avoir une relation
avec le président Poutine au début et
que ça n'a rien donné en pratique donc
il a constaté que ça donnait rien que
c'était peut-être trop tard ou beaucoup
trop tôt j'en sais rien bon en tout cas
la France aujourd'hui n'est pas en train
de chercher la ce que vous dites c'est
une expression
originale qui pèserait sur euh sur
l'issue d's le système actuel politico
médiatique en
Europe après que Poutine a disons
réveillé l'esprit défense dans le tempan
donc le temp n'a pas été aussi présent
dans les esprits depuis euh 20 ans 30
ans donc c'est pas le moment mais
peut-être
que ça reviendra peut-être est-ce que
vous imaginez la Russie poussé jusque au
pays baltes envahir les pays baltes
envahir la Pologne ensuite continuer
dans S lancer et arriver jusqu'à Paris
est-ce que qu quand j'allume mon poste
de télé j'entends dire
oui il ne s'arrêtera pas il va continuer
l'économie de guerre russe est lancée ça
représente une menace c'est vrai c'est
pas vrai est-ce que l'économie de guerre
russe représente
infin un danger mortel ou est-ce que
c'est un fantasme pour pouvoir
galvaniser les opinions publiques et
mobiliser de l'argent et de l'armement
pour défendre l'Ukraine ben on peut pas
démontrer ni vous ni moi aujourd'hui que
c'est vrai ou que c'est faux bon alors
et dans le bénéfice du doute vaut mieux
les arrêter tout de suite mon sentiment
à moi c'est que je je comprends pas
comment Poutine même s'il a pris un
risque à mon avis absurde cruel mais
absurde en attaquant l'Ukraine pourquoi
il attaquerait maintenant l' temp qui
n'a pas attaqué depuis le début alors le
entreetemps l'esprit de défense s'est
réveillé l' temp s'est réorganisé les
pays neutres sont rentrés dans l' tempan
il y a maintenant une présence par
exemple autanienne énorme américaine
énorme dans les pays baltes ce qui était
déjà le cas non beaucoup plus qu'avant
beaucoup plus une sorte de mur qui a été
construit entre les pays baltes et leurs
voisins biéloruses il y a des manœuvres
me de l' temp il y a quelques semaines
qui avait jamais eu lieu là bon donc
pourquoi maintenant Poutine en
202425 pourquoi il se lançit dans une
opération de ce type ça me paraît
complètement absurde complètement ogique
alors je comprends que dans certains
pays qui étaient neutre pour justifier
devant le Parlement qu'on abandonne la
neutralité et qu'on va donc rejoindre le
temps il faut ils peuvent pas dire on
rejoindre le temps mais il y a pas de
problème particul
ils ont besoin de dire dans ces pays on
rejoint le temp parce que la la menace
est imminente ça veut dire qu'elle le
choix mais on peut comprendre le en
politique intérieure qu'il y a des
arguments de ce
type bon mais ça prouve pas non plus que
qu'il va attaquer encore une fois je
vois pas par quel enchaînement par
quelle folie parce que pour le coup
c'est le système otanien tout entier et
qui se réveil l'Amérique est obligé de
dire la Chine on s'en occupera plus tard
il son obl de remettre le paquet et
c'est pas possible de de laisser faire
ça parce que l'Amérique peut pas laisser
tomber la l'alliance sinon ça garanti
vaut plus rien dans le monde ils sont
plus puissances numéro 1 c'est trop
dangereux même les américains les plus
déterminés à ne pas entrer dans
l'enronnage de la guerre etve que la
Russie ne peuvent pas rester sans réagir
Poutine le sait tout ça donc je n'y
crois pas mais comme on peut pas le
démontrer même si j'adhère pas à l'idée
on est en 38 et Poutine va tout envahir
bon on n pas besoin de raconter des
choses comme ça pour être convaincu
qu'il faut pour le moment aider l'armée
ukrainienne à mieux résister on n pas
besoin de mélanger les deux mais ça peut
pas se démontrer donc personnellement
j'approuve quand même le renforcement
des pays baltes j'approuve la le
renforcement de la Défense des pays
baltes j'approuve les manœuvres qui ont
eu lieu dans le dans le nord de l'Europe
et je pense qu'il faut également
protéger de la même façon la Moldavie et
il y a deux trois endroits comme
caliningrade qui sont des endroits
donc plus on va renforcer plus on sera
dissuasif je dit au début tout en disant
que l'Occident aurait dû être beaucoup
plus malin astucieux stratège qui signe
Guerrien pendant 10 15 ans j'ai dit que
dans les 10 années suivantes on n pas
été assz
dissuasif donc c'est le moment de l'être
beaucoup on n pas besoin de croire à une
attaque imminente pour faire ça quand
vous étiez ministre des Affaires
étrangères comment ça se passe une
journée de ministre des Affaires
étrangères quand il y a un point chaud
qui se manifeste vous avez les services
de renseignement qui vous qui vous
abreuvent qui vous qui vous
nourrissent vous pouvez diligenter
quelques ressources sur place pour avoir
une perception plus fine comment ça se
passe Stéphan ses journé comment comment
il s'informe aujourd B je peux bah il
faudra lui demander mais je peux faire
que des réponses banales sauf que dans
les 20 ou 30 dernières années il y a de
plus en plus d'information qui grouille
dans tous les
sens
mais la question c'est de hiérarchiser
justement vous êtes quand vous êtes un
ministre important ou un président vous
avez tout un système qui monte vers vous
il faut avoir l'œil quoi faut avoir
l'œil il faut que des gens autour
arrivent à trier à distinguer
99 % des information qui circule ne
change rien n'apporte rien il y a pas
d'élément nouveaux ça change rien à
l'analyse et si vous avez une analyse
personnelle un peu historique un peu
historique je là-dessus avec un peu de
bouteille qu est B parce qu'on peut
apprendre l'histoire très jeune en
l'expérience aide beaucoup quand on a vu
dans chaque pays pares présenté plus
fonctionner plusieurs présidents
américains vous distinguez mieux le
conjoncturel et le structurel même chose
dans les autres pays en tout cas dans le
grouillement d'information vous devez
avoir une sorte d'esprit au laser
làdedans qui distingue donc il faut
choisir des très très bons collaborateur
qui a la même capacité en triangle dans
ce magma voilà il y a une information
qui est nouvelle et qui change tout ou
qui est menaçante ou encourageante faut
pas se tromper là-dessus mais en même
temps il faut gérer l'opinion qui est
hyper agité enthousiasmé ou angoissé par
des tas de trucs qui sont qui n'ont
aucune importance souv aucune même si
c'est disonst émotionnellement terrible
il y a des émotions parce qu'il y a des
drames atroces bon et puis les gens
sontt en chanté parce qu'il passait ceci
ou cela aucune importance donc de plus
en plus dans ces grands postes
politiques dans les démocraties modernes
il faut gérer les deux en même
temps savoir qui on est où on va faut
avoir une comme ça une étoile polaire
là-bas savoir où on va et puis en même
temps gérer le l'opinion certains car je
je dis pas qu'il faut négliger parce que
on est dans des démocraties d'opinion et
puis les les gens qui sont émus sont
sincères en fait donc faut pas le faut
pas le traiter avec désinvolture il y a
aucune condescendance ce que je dis mais
simplement j'ai dit que c'est pas le
même le même job donc les présidents et
les grands ministres ils ont deux jobs
en même temps par rapport à
ça on parle un peu d'Afrique si vous
voulez on parle de propagande russe en
Afrique contre notre beau pays comment
on a pu laisser faire ça comment on n'
pas pu anticiper ça quand j'entends à
gauche à droite nous les français on
paye un Stringer 30000 € pour mettre
notre propagande sur les réseaux sociaux
africain quand il y en a d'autres qui
payent des des influenceurs 300 400000 €
qui galvanisent les foules comment nous
on n pas eu cette vision cette pensée
stratégique de voir les choses et
maintenant on a plus accès à nos anciens
copains africains nos anciennes colonies
n nos anciennes
francophonies on a laissé les Russes et
les Chinois nous nous Boutter hors
d'Afrique ça va être compliqué de
revenir alors je vois les choses un peu
différemment mais allez-y mais c'est pas
pour dire le contraire c'est qu'il y a
une autre entrée dans le sujet alure
actuelle dans le sud global entre
guillemets encore une fois il est très
hétéroclite mais on assiste à une
rhtorique antioccidentale très forte
antiançaise attendez antioccidentale
globale après ça dépend où notamment
post-occidental alors il y a la version
un peu CHU disant vous avez gouverné le
monde pendant des siècles maintenant
c'est d'où on va prendre notre revanche
ok comme dans le sport chacun son tour
essayez on verra mais il y a ceux qui
veulent se venger aussi c'est pas la
même chose mais après quand vous avez à
faire à certains endroits précis vous
parlez de l'Afrique je vous pensez au
sel en particulier bon vous avez à faire
des gouvernements nuls incapa corrompu
par ailleurs c'est pas le problème
numéro 1 même si on s'excite en tout cas
nul incapable à un ils ont besoin de
bouc émissaire donc le bouc émissaire
occidental c'est qui c'est le français
là mais ce serait pas le français en
Angola ou en Asie du
Sud-Est c'est le français parce que la
France c'est un peu assz bonne fille en
fait après les
indépendances F de Bo pour la Côte
d'Ivoire sangor pour le Sénégal ils ont
demandé au général de Gaulle de
maintenir des bases en disant garde des
bases parce que sinon être obligé de
faire des armées ils vont faire des PO
donc on maintient des bases à la demande
des pays plus une énorme coopération
pendant très très longtemps on a fait
d'ailleurs un travail magnifique faudra
un rejour quand la l'espect de de
vague complètement mensongère sur le
plan historique sur la M décolonial
apporé des États-Unis névros américaines
en fait alors que l'histoire n'a rien à
voir entre les les Noirs aux États-Unis
et l'histoire des relations enfin ça
c'est un autre sujet faudra le faire un
jour le réécrire un jour bref la France
reste là elle reste là alors que les
Belges qui ont laissé une situation
épouvantable Rwanda Burundi Congo ils
ont disparu personne s'occupe d'eux les
Portugais qui ont laissé deux guerres
civiles monstrueuses Angola Mozambique
tout le monde a oublié la
Grande-Bretagne qui a laissé tomber tout
le monde tout de suite il y a quand même
eu des questions genre Nigéria BIAF
d'État et cetera il y a que la France
qui est restée par un mélange de de
bonne volonté dire de charité chrétienne
transformé en esprit de coopération
l'aide au développement de demande des
de ces pays parce que ces pays avaient
été géré de telle façon qu'il y avait
une communauté de culture qui s'était
créée et de langue il y avait pas la
colonisation à la britannique où il y
avait un très très petit nom d'anglais
en fait qui laissait les autres vivre à
leur façon donc le lien est beaucoup
plus fort donc ça a continuer bon après
il y a l'épisode de la fameuse
France-Afrique qu'on veut arrêter mais
qui a disparu depuis burette c'est
l'époque des financements de campagne
électorale devenu hors de prix par
quelques pays d'Afrique riche comme le
Gabon et qui pay à coup de valise et
cetera bon et c'est fini depuis très
longtemps ça depuis très très longtemps
donc il y a une sorte de
distanciation progressive avec de moins
en moins de gens en France qui
comprennent
l'Afrique encore pas mal de dirigeants
africains qui connaissent mieux parce
qu'il regardent les décisions qui décide
quoi à Paris à Bruxelles à Berlin mais
en fait c'est une distanciation après il
y a la mondial
les Africains sont pas plus bêtes que
les autres donc ils jouent de toutes les
cartes dans la mondialisation et la
France est resté un peu statique et a
répondu à la demande des pays la demande
des pays pour faire des opérations
militaires mais pas la France-Afrique à
l'ancienne où on décidait tout seul
parce que les président ont demandé à
focar et cetera et ce ce qui a
d'ailleurs arrêté énormément de guerre
civile dans l'uf mais par exemple au
Sahel quand le gouvernement malien
malien attaqué par une opération
djihadiste qui veut venir vers Bamako il
est un gouverement légitime par d' je
parle de l'époque Hollande ok au début
voyez il demande à gouvernement légitime
soutenu par les pays voisins il demande
à la France le Conseil de sécurité est
d'accord pour qu' a une intervention
sécurité donc les Russes et les ch sont
pas contre en fait et quand le nuU dit
bon qu'est-ce qui capable d'intervenir
on fait le tour de la salle là a
personne sauf la France parce que la
force d'interposition africaine promise
depuis 15 ans n'existe pas donc la
France un peu brave fille dit ok on va
on va bloquer le truc et Hollande a tout
à fait raison au début il est courageux
il a raison l'erreur c'est sans doute
d'être resté après trop longtemps un peu
comme les Occidentaux et les américains
en Afghanistan donc a tout un
enchaînement qui aboutit au fait que il
y a pas de raison que la présence
française en Afrique Seram une présence
militaire même si c'était devenu le cas
à la demande des Africains à la demande
des Africains il y a une cinquantaine de
pays en Afrique et là où on se sont
rejetés par les Russes et cetera c'est
quoi 400 pays 400 pays qui vont nous
supplier dans 10ant de les débarrasser
de Wagner bon on verra ce que ça
deviendra la question chinoise c'est
différent parce qu'ils ont jamais
cherché à supplanter les occidentaux sur
le plan de la sécurité ils ont construit
oui bah eux c'est l'accès il consent
c'est des prétextes mais c'est l'accès
aux matières premières aux terres
cultivables et cetera il développent la
présence à Djibouti par rapport à ça
mais il y a pas de concurrence apparente
directe avec les Russes c'est beaucoup
plus frustre beaucoup plus simpliste ça
concerne un petit nombre de pays mais il
faut pas confondre ce qui se passe au
Mali Burkina Niger pour moi le le
Sénégal c'est autre chose le vote
populaire populiste c'est différent bon
bref il faut relativiser et je crois que
si la France s'y prend bien avec un un
discours peut-être un petit peu
différent elle est tout à fait la
bienvenue dans les tris/4 de l'Afrique à
condition de pas arriver en roulant les
mécaniques on est les Français faut nous
donner l'aéroport et le pont quoi ça ça
marche pas il les mine faut accepter
d'être mis en concurrence avec
l'ensemble des autres d'autant que les
Africains ils commencent à à dire qu'ils
veulent pas rester en tête à- tête avec
les Chinois donc il y a beaucoup de
cartes à jouer comment vous voyez les
flux migratoires comment vous voyez euh
la Libye comment vous voyez les flux
aujourd'hui l'Europe vote euh le PCT
immigration avec des choses qui sont
complètement hallucinantes dedans
comment vous voyez ça là est-ce que vous
voyez une garde prétorienne européenne
contre les flux migratoires est-ce que
vous voyez un mur bientôt construit aux
portes de
l'Europe je discutais il y a pas il y a
une petite dizaine d'années avec
quelqu'un de très très très très très
très bien renseigné et il me dit
l'Europe ne sait pas encore où elle va
construire son mur entre parenthèses
comme aux États-Unis comment vous voyez
l'instrumentalisation des flux
migratoire par Pierre Paul jaacques ou
Vladimir bon ce qui m'intéresse c'est
pas
l'instrumentalisation qui n'a lieu que
quand le phénomène n'est pas géré la
militarisation des flux migratoires non
c'est choseérce qu' a une
solution alors d'un point de vue
anthropologique c'est évident que
contenu du fait que tout le monde est au
courant de
tout que c'est assez facile de voyager
c'est pas très cher de
voyager des systè de passeur
incroyablement développé notamment en
Afrique mais pas qu'en Afrique qui
d'illeur gagne plus d'argent sur
l'immigration illégale que sur la drogue
c'est phénoménal et c'est un phénomè qui
con cerne les États-Unis et l'Europe
notamment mais il y a d'autres
phénomènes puisque en Afrique les les
vrais pauvres vont vers la Côte d'Ivoire
ou le Nigéria ou l'Afrique du Sud qui
dit sans arrêt qu' Amar d'être envahi
l'Afrique du Sud il a des campagne de
presse sur ce thème bon donc c'est un
phénomène durable et on peut pas dire
ben c'est comme ça on y peut rien les
gens ont le droit d'aller où ils veulent
ou même en pire nous les Européens on a
tellement malagie qu'on va donner àile à
des milliards de gens du monde entier
bon et on peut pas dire l'inverse non
plus en disant on va tout arrêter tout
fermer c'est juste impraticable
impratiable c'est absurde donc on est
obligé de gérer les phénomènes mais ne
pas les gérer sous prétexte que c'est
impossible catastrophique ça fait monter
tous les parties les plus les plus
extrêmes qui n'ont pas de solution en
plus dire c'est toujours arrivé c'est
arrivé sans arrêt en mélangeant avec les
visigo et les Vikings et CER jamais dans
ces proportions absurde jamais comme ça
ça peut fonctionner finalement très bien
si ça concerne pas trop de gens c'est
quoi pas trop pas trop ça dépend des ça
dépend des pays ça dépend des moments ça
dépend du taux de chômage de plein de
trucs pas trop de gens pas trop vite
avec des gens qui veulent en fait
s'intégrer et des gens qu'on a la
capacité et l'envie d'intégrer pour le
moment aucune de ces conditions n'est
réunie
donc la seule solution la seule approche
qui me paraît sérieuse c'est ce que
disent les gens de la gauche
scandinav maintenant après avoir
pratiqué l'inverse notamment au Danemark
air pratiqué l'inverse qui était
l'ouverture l'ouverture totale et puis
on a un passé chargé donc il faut
accueillir tout le monde etyz ce mélange
de moralisme de et ça marche pas c'est
catastrophique si les pays scandinaves
ont changer notamment la gauche pas
uniquement sous la pression de l'extrême
droite en scandinav qui est le résultat
de la non gestion du phénomène c'est
précisément qu'il arrivai à des à des
situations qui mettent en cause la la
sécurité la vie dans les villes
l'enseignement les hôpitaux et C et ca
donc moi je suis à fond pour une gestion
en disant on va négocier on va dire
Schengen Shengen en gros Shengen mais
c'est vrai aux États-Unis c'est vrai
dans d'autres régions du monde Shengen
doit négocier tous les gens tous les
deux avec les pays de départ et de
transit des quotas par métier parce
qu'on a besoin de plein de gens plein de
gens en fait mais c'est pas ces gens-là
qui arrivent il a pas ces gens-là qui
arrivent il y a les passeurs d'autre
part il y a le phénomène qu'on a nié
pendant longtemps pe plus le nié qui est
qu'une grande parti de ceux qui viennent
en Europe sont musulmans redevenus
islamistes pas les musulmans qui posent
un problème d'ailleurs les ceux que les
les les les patrons des grandes firmes
d'automobile faisaient venir deux
générations avant qui étaient des
Algériens en général ça posé aucun
problème ni de religion ni de mode de
vie par rapport à ça mais ça a changé
entretemps donc il faut faire ça mais si
vous prenez une mesure isolée
elle va être soit trop laxiste soit trop
dure donc il faut un plan d'ensemble un
plan d'ensemble après pour sortir de
l'espect de situation intermédiaire
encore que le PACT Agier l'immigration
est un progrès à mon avis vous l'avez lu
je connais les j'ai pas tout lu dans le
détail mais c'est des compromis il y a
27 pays mais le simple fait que les 27
pays arrivent à se dire faut mieux gérer
le truc c'est mieux que le dénni
n'oubliez pas que pendant des des années
les gens qui disaient il y a un problème
d'immigration on leur dit vous êtes des
racistes c'est complètement absurde
comme comme réaction c'est pas le sujet
donc je suis à fond pour une gestion de
ce type et pour passer de la situation
actuelle et reconcentrer le droit
d'asile qu'il faut pas abandonner c'est
notre âme même rappelez-vous l'asile
dans les les église au Moyen-Âge c'est
l'âme de l'Europe ça faut pas
l'abandonner mais il est totalement
détour enfin presque totalement détourné
donc faut le reconcentrer sur les gens
en danger qu'on va continuer à protéger
donc ça veut dire ce que je dis là c'est
facile à dire je reconnais que c'est
très compliqué à faire mais il faut un
plan d'ensemble sinon chaque mesure
isolée ne passera jamais après les pays
du dont j'ai parlé de départ et de
transit il vont dire non jamais pas de
forteresse Europe et cetera parce que
ils ont besoin que plein de gens parlent
parce qu'ils arrivent pas à les à les
gérer après ils envoient énormément de
d'argent à leur famille mais c'est
complètement malsin ça va mal tourner ça
va tourner à la
catastrophe on le voit bien dans la les
banlieux de la plupart des grandes
villes de l'ensemble de l'Europe je me
rappelle en plus d'Assan 2 le roi du
Maroc disant à François miter en 82
c'est vieux hein il faut arrêter le
regroupement familial un mitéran lui dit
mais c'est cruel les familles ont pas
d'être Rud non non non vous y arriverez
jamais si vous n'arrêtez pas ça c'est
impossible à contrôler impossible à
juguler vous aurez des réseaux des getos
et et cetera bon il y a énormément de
gens qui ont dit ça depuis des années
notre plus grand anthropologue
levos a dit à une époque toutes les
civilisations ont le droit de se
défendre même la nôtre al tout le monde
est tombé dessus parce que voyez donc
j'ai un point de vue j'ai un plan en
tête peut-être
inapplicable mais je vous étonne
apparemment en disant que pour moi le
PACT as l'immigration des Européens
c'est c'est mieux qu'avant c'est si
c'est toujours un bon
début c'est un progrès c'est ve dire que
les Européens sont quand même conscients
du fait que c'est un problème déjà vous
avez déjà discuté avec une suédoise de
22 ans j'ai discuté avec des Européens
je sais pas ce qui est l'Europe mais je
connais je sais assez ce que sont les
Européens oui mais c'est un compromis ce
pacte donc c'est plutôt mieux qu'avant
parce que l'idée d'avant c'est qu'il y a
pas de problème la la commissaire
actuelle à l'immigration en Europe qui
est une polonaise
elle dit c'est très bien on a réglé les
problèmes on a démontré bon c'est
exactement l'inverse depuis des années
ça ne fait que s'aggraver donc si on
veut pas que ça tourne à la catastrophe
vraie moi je suis David d'aller dans le
sens de ce Pact
et la loi française qui était tellement
combattu était un un tout petit progrès
dans la dans une direction utile on sera
obligé d'arriver à la à l'proche
scandinave les outils la mer Rouge les
outils qui bombardent les c'est autre
chose ça oui c'est un peu à côté oui on
en parle oui est-ce que est-ce que le
fait qu'il se prépare à aller attaquer
les câbles internet qui passent devant
chez
eux à ce qui se passe à
Gaza poussé par les Iraniens bah il y a
deux énormes conflits qui se mélangent
là je vous t déperche non mais vous
connaissez le sujet bon les outils c'est
des c'est des chites sous un autre nom
au Yémen qui sont en guerre contre
l'Arabie et contre les Yéménites sunit
qui sont sous influence saoudienne donc
une guerre Arabie Iran au Yémen entre
les houtistes et les autres ça c'est la
guerre en soit qui dure depuis des
années des années avec différentes
tentatives pour apaiser les choses en
faisant des compromis alors soit en
gardant le même Yémen ou en revenant au
Yémen du Nord et du Sud ça dépend des
cas mais là il y a une divergence
maintenant entre Abou Dhabi donc
mbz et l'arabi MBS c'est le nom des des
dirigeants en résumé parce que veut pas
la reconstitution d'un d'un Yamen en de
morceaux donc a une partie qui serait
hostile puis se met la sal les
différentes tendance et ni au sein de
l'islam bon c'est une question en soi on
pourrait dire c'est horrible parce qu'il
y a énormément de morts au Yémen dont
tout le monde se fiche en Occident mais
on pe dire c'est c'est confiné c'est un
sujet en soi mais le lien arrive avec
l'autre sujet puisque il y a la au proch
riant il y a les conséquences qui
réapparaissent d'une non règlement de la
question palestinienne qui avait été
présenté comme étant dépassé
oublié donc toute la le travail très
très très courageux de la minorité
israélienne qui s'était résigné à
l'acceptation d'un État palestinien et
qui avait en face d'elle à un moment
donné pendant 10 15 ans magnifiques la
minorité palestinienne qui s'était
résignéex d'Israël donc il y a eu des
gens incroyablement courageux que j'ai
tous connu parce que ça coincida avec
les années an ou les anné Chirac bon
mais finalement après l'époque de en
Israël Rabine perz solmert etoud Barak
et même même Charon à la fin en fait
après il y a l'époque netanahou qui dont
l'axe principal c'est jamais d'État
palestinien donc il a encouragé la
colonisation à outron 106 Jordanie et
cetera et cetera et puis une situation à
Gaza où même même Sarkozi qu'on
attendait pas sur ce sujet avait dit
c'est l'enfer sur terre Gaza alors
c'était maintenu à un niveau faible de
subsistence en laissant les Qataris
payer en demandant au Catari de payer au
minimum mais quelqu'un comme eoud Barak
qui est même pas un militant du camp de
la paix qui était un premier ministre
travaiste donc on va dire centregauche
mais mais pas plus il a dit dans plein
d'interviews netanou a tout fait a tout
fait pour que la situation palestin soit
la pire et que les gens crédibles soient
écartés qui a que le Hamas donc il a une
sorte de jeu
diabolique d'un TER qui bref tout ça
paraissait complètement archaïque
absurde dépassé par la politique de
Trump l'alliance d'Abraham qui a joué
sur le fait que les gouvernements arabes
on on R lebol et veulent
neutraliser cette question palestinienne
et normaliser qu'Israël les gouvernement
je parle pas des peuples alors dans les
pays où il y a pas de peuple genre Abou
Dhabi c'est pas dangereux parce que le
peuple c'est des gens c'est des immigré
en fait mais l'Arabie et tout ça ils ont
été très très loin dans la normalisation
sans rien obtenir pour les palestinien
avec l'idée on s'en fiche ils ont perdu
c'est plus sujet bon donc dans mon
analyse à moi qui est très proche de de
l'ancien camp de la paix en Israël qui
renaist en ce moment d'ailleurs ils ont
apporté la bombardotement Gaza comme sur
un plateau aux Iraniens même si c'est
pas eu qu'on déclenchait une connexion
Iran Hamas voilà bon tout ça c'est une
espè d'enchaînement pathétique c'est ce
que j'ai vu de plus il y a quelques cas
où j'ai vu la France essayer de faire le
mieux hein pour empêcher des conflits
les régler mais ça c'est quand même un
de ceux que j'ai vécu de l'intérieur
c'est c'est absolument horrible parce
que les les les les 10 15 20 ans du
processus de paix c'était pour empêcher
ce qui s'est passé pour qu'il jamais les
attaque at trocce du du Hamas du 7
octobre jamais les l'orreur de la guerre
de Gazin c'est é ça dans la tête des des
gens que j'ai franquenté bon ça échoué
complètement alors bref c'est toujours
là on sait pas comment ça va tourner on
peut y revenir si vous voulez mais en
tout cas les outils en profitent et donc
les outils qui à un moment donné étit
tenté il y a une bataille chez eux en
plus de leadership il y a pas que les
frères outil il y a tout un une
population làdedans bon qui était tenté
se résigner à un arrangement plus ou
moins bon pour eux ils en profitent et
ils ont compris que quand même il y
avait un tel trafic par la mer Rouge et
le canal de chaise notamment tout ce qui
est hoc les portes conteneur qui
viennent d'Asie c'est quand même une des
veines jugulaires de l'Europe par
rapport à ça donc il lance des attaques
pour insécuriser le passage qui fait que
les grands armateurs mondiaux sont oblés
de faire le tour par l'Afrique c'est
beaucoup plus cher les assurances
montent les Américains et les Anglais
ont essayé de réagir il nont pas été
jusqu'à faire une opération au sol
faudrait faire une autre guerre faudrait
envahir toute la côte du Yémen qui est à
l'entrée de la la mer Rouge bon ils en
sont là donc on voit pas au jour où nous
parlons de scénario rapide pour calmer
les outils qui laisseraiit les bateaux
passer il faudrait qu'il y a un
processus qu' une relance de processus
de solution
Israël-Palestine ce qu'espère Biden et
son équipe mais il faudrait pour ça que
netanahu était écarté remplacé par
quelqu'un d'autre qui est ressorti de
prison un leader palestinien pour
déclencher un processus que les pays
arabes soient revenus dans le jeu à ce
moment-là les pays arabes diraient
notamment l'Arabie il faut sécuriser la
mer
Rouge ce qui ne fonctionnerait que si
l'Iran n'a pas intérêt à faire l'inverse
donc il faudrait que il une menace sur
l'Iran qu' se rend compte que c'est trop
dangereux de continuer à exciter les
outils même dans un une période qui sera
un processus de solution en vue qui est
même pas le cas aujourd'hui même pas le
cas d'imaginer un processus mais on n
même pas là- que est-ce qu'on fait une
expérience de pensé une autre est-ce que
vous voyez Israël bombarder directement
l'Iran là il y a l'Iran qui fait des
menaces sur le des mesures de rétorsion
après le bombardement de leur consulat
en Syrie est-ce que vous
voyez Israël ça se ferme difficilement
mais il faut le mettre à la
verticale
c'est pas mal ça c'est
français c'est très
bon est-ce que vous voyez Israël
bombarder directement au nucléaire
l'Iran alors on peut pas simplement dire
Israël c'est un pays très démocratique
il y a un débat permanent qui peut aller
très très loin qui est formidable qui
est extraordinaire intellectuellement en
plus ils peuTent pas se traiter
d'antisémite mutuellement donc là ça
donne une liberté de de penser
magnifique pourquoi vous faites ça
est-ce que est-ce que l'accusation
d'antisémitisme est une façon de faire
taire l'adversaire alors moi j'ai
constaté en tout cas historiquement que
les grands leaders israéliens qui
cherchaient la solution ne parlent
jamais de l'antisémitisme en Europe ou
ailleurs c'était pas leur sujet en fait
alors en plus il y a tout le débat qui
est que c'est essentiellement dans une
partie du monde musulman réislamisé et
cetera je voulais pas souler le sujet
mais j'en ai pas besoin en fait donc
jamais Rabine ou Pez serurait dit ça
donc c'est c'est un autre sujet un autre
sujet qui qui a pas tellement de lien
avec l'affaire du Proche Orient que
quelque chose qui est lié à à l'histoire
particulière de l'opinion publique en
France ou en Allemagne ou en Italie et
cetera et cetera en tout cas les les
gens qui cherchaient une solution
n'avaient pas besoin de cet argument en
fait c'est netaniah qui a commencé à se
servir de ça pour terroriser les les
diplomates
européens qui avait le le culot de dire
encore il y a peut-être un problème
palestinien réglé ah vous êtes un un
antisémite ah oui excusez-moi je vous
demande pardon bon donc ça c'est
l'époque nthaniaou pas son premier
gouvernement mais quand il est revenu
après ça fait maintenant plus de 12 ans
avec toute une série d'alliés vraiment
extrammistes y compris il y a des chefs
de parti dans le gouver je parle pas du
cabinet de guerre il y a des les anciens
chefs d'état-major il y a des gens très
très bien comme le général gansz par
exemple mais dans le gouvernement
netagou qu'il est obligé de de
constituer pour rester au pouvoir donc
pour éviter les les les suites Jud le
concernant pour pour pour d'autres
raisons il y a des chefs de parti qui à
l'époque s'étaient réjoui de
l'assassinat de Rabine pour voir ce que
c'est donc on peut pas dire Israël donc
ça dépend alors dans Israël
d'aujourd'hui il y a unanimité sur le
fait qu'il faut éradiquer le le Habas
même si l'armée elle-même dit bah on a
fait tout ce qu'on a pu après on peut
faire des opértion commandau mais on
peut pas raser tout ce qui reste mais
l'opignon encore traumatisé par les
horreurs du du 7 octobre parce que ça
fait vraiment pog Grom donc on comprend
la réaction l'opignon est très là-dessus
même des gens assez pacifiques même des
gens qui défendent l'idée qu'il faut
relancer la recherche la solution à deux
états c'est étonnant parce que après le
7 octobre cette option devrait tomberé à
0 % sous l'effet du traumatisme mais
dans un sondage j'ai pas vérifié
récemment mais en janvier notamment dans
le journal
et qui est un journal de centre gauche
très courageux en Israël il y avait un
sondage qui montrait que 25 % si je me
trompe pas des des Israéliens voulaient
virer tous les
Palestiniens un peu comme quand aux
États-Unis un président avait déporté
tous
lesindiiens l' attende en génocide
comment en mode génocide non non non
expulsion non pas tuer al non il y a
quelques rabins fous qui disent ça mais
ça compte pas ça non les Israéliens sont
quand même pas comme ça donc il y avait
l'idée faut les expulser vers l'Égypte
Jordanie ça va détruire tout le
Moyen-Orient mais on s'en ficheement
mais 25 % mais 31 % en janvier avec en
tête la fur du 7 octobre accepter l'idée
de la recherche d'une solution à deux
états donc c'est quand même un pays
extraordinaire il y a un potentiel ce
qui fait que certains membres du
l'ancien camp de la paix qui s'était
désespéré découragé chous netanahou où
il y a des très belles figures des des
des ONG des intellectuels des des
romanciers mais aussi plein d'anciens
militaires plein d'anciens militaires et
aussi Barnavi qui est un historien
extraordinaire qui est ambassadeur de
d'Israël en France à un moment donné
donc il y a quand même 31 % de gens qui
acceptte cette idée et les gens de
encore une fois de ce Gand de la pire
ressuscité entre guillemets ils se
disent plusque les Israéliens ont pu
voir que la politique la plus
implacable contre les les Palestiniens
en sjordanie et à Gaza n'a même pas
garanti leur sécurité puisque le 7
octobre est les horreurs du 7 octobre
ils vont peut-êtreêtre retrouver le
raisonnement d' SAAC Rabine qui est
l'homme le plus courageux que j'ai
rencontré de ma vie qui avait combattu
les Palestiniens sévèrement pendant la
première Intifada je leur brisé les
autres ça qui avait fait le cheminement
donc ils se disent peut-être sauf que
netaniaahou contrôle très bien sa
majorité de 64 députés à la C et que
Biden a vous montré que il attend sa
mise à l'écart pour jouer sur le général
Gans et après il jou bargouti il y a
tout un processus qui est en tête ça
bouge pas pour le moment ça bouge pas
donc il y a pas d'espoir dans l'immédiat
de cette solution ce qui se passe à ser
la moins
pire ce qui se passe à Gaza en ce moment
avec un déferlement de
[Musique]
bombe
une population à Gaza qui est poussée de
plus en plus de plus en plus de plus en
plus au
sud comment on appelle ça c'est un
génocide c'est pas un génocide c'est une
opération militaire spéciale c'est une
opération militaire tout court non
opération militaire spéciale c'est le
terme de Poutine sur
l'Ukraine c'est une vengeance c'est se
défendre est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il
faut faut par est-ce qu'il faut être
plus bourreau que le
bourreau et ça c'est une question
extérieure ou qui vient après du point
de vue des
Israéliens même encore une fois des gens
qui déteste netanahou qui manifestait
toutes les semaines contre lui pour
d'autres raisons même les gens qui sont
dans des ONG magnifique et qui dénonce
le comportement des colons en
sjordanie bon
même ces gens-là ils disent on n pas le
choix on n pas le choix on est obligé de
on est obligé de de détruire le Hamas au
minimum la branche militaire du Hamas
donc ils ont il faut comprendre ça peu
importe le nom qu'on donne à ça en fait
mais n'importe quel peuple placé dans
les mêmes conditions réagirait comme ça
voyz il y a c'est quelque chose
d'implacable on a vu ça dans d'autres
dans d'autres histoires donc mais ça
veut pas ça ne définit pas les
Israéliens politiquement et ça nous dit
rien sur l'avenir parce que les mêmes
sont tout à fait capables de dire moi je
soutiens l'action notre action à Gaza on
n' pas le choix c'est atroce mais on n'
pas le choix même siz les militaires qui
parlent pas mal quand même disent B on a
fait le job on a plus d'objectif
militaire il commencec à dire ça maisons
de T salale mais les mêmes qui
soutiennent l'opération sont capabl de
dire oui il faut relancer une
négociation il y a pas de de
contradiction entre les quel que soit le
terme alors après le débat jeuncide
c'est très très compliqué parce que là
il y a des tas de débats et pas que là
en disant comment le qualifier bon euh
la l'Afrique du Sud a fait une opération
auprès de la Cour de justice qui qui
sont de la cour de la Cour pénale
internationale et qui s'en est sorti en
disant il faut prendre des précautions
pour que ce soit qu'il y ait pas un
engrenage qui y conduisent mais la
définition du génocide qui a été adopté
en 45 il y a plusieurs définitions
possibles il faut que je sois vraiment
intentionnel intentionnel programmé il
faut qu'il y ait un plan quoi un plan
genre conférence de vanzé pour la la la
choix bon il y a pas tellement de cas où
c'est organisé penser à l'avance il a
quelques cas on on arrive à 5 6 mais dès
qu'on touche à ce sujet c'est tellement
douloureux tellement sensible il y a de
de telle bataille de de juriste dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
que c'est impossible de conclure en
réalité dans la plupart des cas mais
dans la pratique ça revient au même à
mon avis pour les gens qui meurent ça
revient au même quel que soit le nom
sous lequel il meurt donc revenons à
notre sujet moi je suis pas la ni la
Cour de justice ni la Cour Pénale je
peux pas trancher comme ça en
choisissant un terme plutôt qu'un autre
je crois que ce qui se passe c'est la
fatalité au sens tragédie antique ce qui
se passe la la la non le non réglement
du problème n'était pas inéluctable il y
a eu plein plein plein d'occasions
manqué dans la situation créée depuis
maintenant 10 15 ans une opération
georama c'était sans doute inéductable
un jour il aurait fallu la prévenir par
une polique complètement différente la
réaction
est sans doute était impossible à éviter
c'est impossible que Israël dise on
s'est Tromp on va négocier avec Monsieur
hamasar impossible impossible donc c'est
la fatalité parce qu'en même temps
l'image d'Israël c'est AG grave soit
effondré soit aggravé dans les 3/ du
monde et même dans l'Occident
qui israélien pour 36 raisons on voit
bien qu' une petite frangeche de la
jeunesse notamment étudiante qui a
basculé de l'autre côté et qu' on est au
point d'ailleurs soutenir le Hamas même
pas la solution à deux états donc a un
prix à payer terrible euh pour
maintenant et très très très longtemps
par les Israéliens sauf sil s'est
corrigé dans 6 mois dans un an par
relance d'un processus de paix
aboutissant une solution qu'on a fail
obtenir qu'on n' pas eu il y a 20 ou 30
ans qui recorrigerait l'image alors si
on voulait
être merveilleusement idéaliste il faut
imaginer un moment mais je sais même pas
quand rendez compte où un un premier
ministre palestinien de l'État
palestinien irait s'incliner demander
pardon dans les kbuts et vous veriez un
premier ministre israélien de cette
époque aller à Gaza demander pardon VO
je l'ai dit exprès pour que on mesure
les la distance entre les deux est-ce
que ça vous parle l'arithmétique de la
rébellion ça dépend de qui vous parlez
je vous parlez je vais parler comme un
militaire français l'arithmétique de la
rébellion ça vous parle bombarder un
terroriste allez on cherche dans ma tête
c'est renvoieé à
gueria petits groupes qui ont la
capacité non non c'est imaginez-vous je
suis général
colonel je déclenche un bombardement
pour aller chercher un deux terroristes
au milieu de civil et puis j'en tue
quatre autres de sa famille qui
n'avaient rien à
voir la famille des quatre autres se
transforme en terroriste pour venger la
mort de ceux qui sont morts pour
rien et de fil en aiguille on tombe sur
une fonction exponentielle de terrorisme
de vengeance de
haine est-ce que vous pensez que
l'opération israélienne à Gaza
va générer pour les 30 prochaines années
des attentats terroristes des gens qui
vont détester Israël des gens qui vont
aller persécuter des Juifs en dehors
d'Israël est-ce que la réaction
disproportionnée n'a pas été bien
calculé mais il faut à nouveau remonter
à à l'origine à l'origine de la non
solution parce que pour qu' un moment
donné israéliens se disent on a une
autre
option on n'est pas on n'est pas
contraint de faire la l'opération de de
vengeance de représaille fallait qu'il y
ait une autre option mais qui était
étouffée avant abandonnée interdite
avant donc il faut faire toute la faut
rembobiner toute la toute la bobine
quand on en arrive à la situation
d'Israël d'aujourd'hui avec les
gouvernements qu'on connaît depuis une
douzaine d'années et le 7 octobre il y a
pas d'autrre solution sauf qu'elle
pourrait s'arrêter avant mais vous avez
vu le débat quand Biden dit depuis des
semaines ou blen il faut arrêter faire
une trêve les a disent non si on arrête
le Hamas renait tout de suite donc ça
voudrait dire que le Hamas n'est pas
qu'une entité militaire mais également
une entité politique et que finalement
il y a plein de Palestiniens qui
arrivent peut-être un jour d'une
situation de P ça ça remet en cause tout
le raisonnement des nationalistes Isra
en depuis le début et on retombe dans
cet
affrontement terrible accablant triste
entre les musulmans qui n'accepteront
enfin ceux des musulmans qui qui
n'accepteront jamais Israël et les
israliens qui n'accepteront jamais
l'État palestinien donc ça renvoie à ce
que je disais avant sur le courage
extraordinaire des des petits groupes
minoritaires qui ont essayé de de sortir
de cet engrenage donc même réponse à la
question même si la question est
différente oui bien sûr ça ça va
engranger créer tout ça sauf si sauf si
il y a une histoire différente qui se
produit dans un an ou deux alors là on
retombera sur la la distinction au sein
des des Palestiniens entre ceux qui
acceptent la Israël ou pas et n'oubliez
pas il y a un élément qu'il faut ajouter
c'est que les les il y a la bataille au
sein du monde sunnite entre les
islamistes et les autres et les
gouvernements combattent les fr musulman
à mort donc les gouvernements arabes en
ce moment ils font semblant d'être
affligés parce que c'est c'est
épouvantable le spectacle des des
souffances à Gaza les familles les
enfants les hitaux et cetera la famine
la famine organisé mais ils veulent que
les que le Hamas soit détruit les mêmes
d'ailleurs ils ne reviendront dans le
processus de solution
éventuelle que si luamas est complèt
éradiqué et là ils joueront le jeu
contre les Israéliens nationalistes
d'avant qui avait tout saboté de la
recréation d'une autorité palestinenne
crédible mais jamais à Mass donc une
espè de guerre à mort c'est quand même
quand sa date a été le premier aller en
israëlégyptien à l'époque de Bégin ça
date le président égyptien qui fout
arrêter ça c'est sans issue donc il vont
en Israël accueilli par bin qui avait
écrit le L remblement de toutes les
forces de droite nationaliste bin très
embêté d'ailleurs par l'arrivée de de
Saat donc il a un courage dingue il est
assassiné par un Égyptien
islamiste frère musulman donc la
symétrique du du gif fanatique assassiné
Rabine donc n'oubliez pas dans votre
présentation actuelle sur Gaza que les
gouvernement arabe actuel des grands
pays de la région veulent l'éradication
du
Hamas pour ça qu'il le euh ils ont une
sorte de et donc si je pousse le RA
compion apparente si je pousse le
raisonnement ils veulent l'éradication
de
l'Iran non on peut pas éradiquer l'Iran
c'est plus difficile c'est beaucoup plus
vieux que tous ces pays arabes qui ont
été fabriqués à la fin de l'Empire
ottoman et cetera c'est un vrai grand
pays et même quand il y aura plus les
ayatollah je sais pas quand ça sera un
grand pays grand grand pays vrai immense
civilisation ménaire et C alors non les
Arabes voudra en tout cas que l'Iran
soit neutralisé et si possible
que le régime tombe mais dans les
puisqu'on fait pas mal de scénarios à
long terme grâce au temps que vous
donnez dans votre émission originale qui
est formidable sur ce plan si on voy
d'utr plan en tout cas suroui le temp si
on voyait à un moment donné l'Iran
redevenir le pays d'avant le chat d'Iran
qui redeviendrait automatiquement un
pays
émergent dominant on verra mais ça c'est
une projection lointaine on verrait les
pays arabes hyper énervés voir inquiet
par cette domination bon on est pas là
ce qui fait que ils veulent tout faire
contre l'Iran mais ils sont pas
mécontents que ce soit un régime paria
en même temps voyez même s'il faut
peut-être un peu apaiser les la rel ce
que les Saoudiens ont accepté de faire
en relation avec l'Iran et avec l'aide
de la Chine bon tout ça est très
compliqué ça s'embouette énormément qui
c'est qui a chassé le
chat le chat d'Iran qui est-ce qui a été
qui qui était derrière ça non d'abord il
était quand même beaucoup trop
provocateur il pouvait être moderniste
il était d'ailleurs moderniste comme
l'ont été beaucoup de dirigeants
extraordinaires comme atat turque en
Turquie le roi d'Afghanistan qu'on a
oublié
zaircha le roi d'Afghanistan formé à
jançon de sa à Paris qui avait demandé
un grand juriste français connaissant de
Maroc parce qu'il pensait qu'il y avait
des analogies pour faire une
Constitution dans lesquell il y avait le
principe de l'égalité homme-femme en
Afghanistan on a trouvé le jurist
c'était Louis fouger un Grand Conseil
d'État il a rédigé la Constitution mais
le roi était renversé avant bon mais il
voulait faire ça le père du chat d'Iran
donc il a des modernisateurs c'est
l'époque également en Égypte ou ailleurs
il y a eu tout un mouvement de pour ça
qu'il faut pas désespérer non plus à
long terme il y a un mouvement de grands
grands modernisateurs et puis après
c'est reparti complètement
euh alors le chat oui c'est un détour
pour répondre pour dire que il en a fait
trop donc il y avait trop de de fêtes
stuairire
percépis le monde entier la Jet 7 des
tonnes de champagne bon il y avait des
reportages sur les les les fêtes au
palais impérial où il y avait donc des
Altesses Royales de partout des vodettes
de cinéma des femmes hyper décolleté des
bijoux bon c'est idiot par enfin c'est
idiot peut pas porter des jugements
comme ça l' porte-pièce mais par rapport
à la population iranienne par rapport au
au paysans
iraniens par rapport à ça donc il a il a
quand même donné des arguments
gigantesques disons à la révolte des
atatol qui ont mis en place un régime
qui est effrayant de effrayant qui est
répressif qui est régressif qui attrroe
pour les femmes mais détesta pour les
autres et CETA qui finira par tomber
parce que la l'ensemble des populations
urbaines de l'Iran en tout cas on on bol
le faire tomber alors à la fin des fins
quand le chat d'Iran qui avait été
transformé aussi d'une façon
grossièrement visible grossièrement
provocatrice en gendarme du golf ce qui
énervait énormément les
Arabes parce que les Occidentaux
disaient le Golf Persique
non golf arabo-persique donc il av une
sorte de tension mais l'Iran était trop
fort pour qu'il puisse contester
beaucoup donc a toute un espect de
processus qui a à mon avis aussi par
arrogance vous parliz d'arrogance sur
d'autres sujets mais on peut l'appliquer
ENF un manque de de finesse quoi de de
PIF politique de sensibilité c'est
vraiment dommage que le chadiron n'it
pas pu
continuer en étant beaucoup plus modéré
un peu plus lent dans la modern laissant
le temps faire les choses qu' est plus
dur jusqu'à la fin passer la couronne à
son fils c'est trop trop damage alors
après à la fin des fins les occidentaux
l'ont laissé tomber il étaitil un moment
donné au je crois au Maroc qui était
courageux non on parle du chat
oui bon la fin est
pathétique mais vous savez que c'est à
l'origine c'est la CIA qui l'avait remis
au
pouvoir dans les années 53 je crois
contre
mossadeg qui voulait qui était un leader
nationaliste qui voulait nationaliser en
partie les pétroles et cetera donc
l'Occident moi je suis occidental par
toutes mes fibres mais et je peux même
redire que je pense que la on n'a jamais
inventé de mieux que la civilisation
occidentale en général et la société
européenne en particulier bon il y a
1000 choses à réformer il y a 1000
choses insupportable en fait quand même
si on par aux autres historiquement et
maintenant c'est quand même formidable
il n'empêche que dans le rapport aux
autres les autres qui ne pensent pas
comme nous comme l'a écrit très bien
le l'ancien diplomate cher pas de Chirac
Maurice gourdau Montagna les autres ne
pensent pas comme nous alors comme nous
on est issu de la chrétienté devenu
l'Occident on est dévoré par l'esprit de
prosélitisme allz évangéliser toutes les
nations a dit Saint- Paul ça vous donne
aller droit gliser tout le monde même
les gens les moins les moins religieux
totalement attés qu ils ont encore c'est
en tête il savent pas d'où ça vient bon
il y a une époque qui a duré longtemps
où les Européens maîtrisaient le monde
bien ou mal bon c'est un autre débat
mais c'est fini ça c'est fini donc une
des grandes grandes questions qui
surplombe de haut la question
quotidienne de la vie diplomatique c'est
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un Occident
carrive va préserver les société
magnifiqu qu'il a dont il a accouché
mais qui soit pas
prosélite qui soit pas trop
interventionniste
ou alors dans des cadres très structurés
décidés par le nuU à la demande des
populations et cetera c'est compliqué ça
ce que je suis en train de dire
profitant de la liberté que vous créez
ici c'est le contraire de ce que pensent
toutes les élitein dans les élites en
tout cas les gens qui ont accès je sais
pas s'il faut dire élite mais les gens
qui ont accès
au débat
public il y en a il y en a que 5 ou 10 %
qui ne pensent pas que notre mission
principale ce soit de répandre nos
valeurs dans le monde entier à coup de
sermon de sanction de bombardement mais
c'est un débat que devant nous parce que
on va pas redevenir majoritaire on va
pas redevenir les patrons du monde qui
vient donc on est obligé d'imaginer
au-delà je parle pas d'Ukraine et Russie
c'est autre chose mais au-delà son oblié
d'imaginer une relation pour
après-demain entre le monde occidental
et le fameux chut global est-ce qu'on
est encore capable d'imaginer est-ce que
le K d'ors est encore capable d'imaginer
est-ce que le département d'État
américain est encore capable d'imaginer
est-ce que est-ce que les Occidentaux
sont capables de se remettre en question
mais c'est pas un problème des machines
diplomatiques c'est un problème
philosophique c'est un problème des
penseurs des analystes des historiens
des philosophes la question est-ce que
quelle va être la relation de l'Occident
au reste du monde après euh c'est autant
une question culturelle linguistique
économique financière technologique et
cetera mais on voit bien que les
aujourd'hui les systèmes diplomatiques
sont très affaiblis en fait ils sont
affaiblis euh parce que la l'activité se
concentre autour des numéroos
1 pour des raisons de d'image presque
inévitable donc toutes ces machines sont
sont très affaiblies il y a il y a 20 ou
30 ans peut-être qu'ils auraient pu
contribuer à à répondre à la question
que j'ai posé mais aujourd'hui moins
moins que jamais quel regard vous portez
sur le le qued
d'oret quel regard vous portez sur j'ai
de Cees sujets parce que moi j'ai adoré
cette maison je l'ai dirigé pendant 5
ans avec un très grand bonheur en
cohabitation
entre Chirac et Jospin j'ai gardé
beaucoup de de lien avec beaucoup de
gens y compris d'ailleurs dans les
mondes diplomatiques étranger le fait
que Macron fasse sauter le corps
diplomatique j'essaie de comment dire de
pas com je pense que je pense que ça
s'imposait pas on va dire par ehémisme
en général je commente pas les les les
politiques les actions des
présidents je peux vous couper une seule
seconde mais je peux vous dire pourquoi
je vous coupe d'abord ou vous vous dites
NON je finis la phrase allez d'accord je
comm parce que comme j'ai vécu donc 20
ans dans le pouvoir pas dans la
politique que j'ai vécu dans l'intimité
de deux présidents que je sais que c'est
quand même très très très compliqué de
plus en plus et que dans les démocraties
d'opinion actuell avec les réseaux ça
devient presque impossible de diriger
les démocraties je suis
extrmement compréhensif sur plein de
trucs mais quand on pose ma question sur
une la question sur un sujet précis je
dis je pense qu'il faut faire ceci ou
cela mais j'ess d'éviter des
commentaires en disant un tel est bon ou
n'est pas bon ce serait trop prétentieux
et trop trop absurde alors que personne
n'a de solution voilà ma réponse est-ce
que Gabriel Atal a mis Stéphan ses
journé au ked d'orset pour contrôler
correctement le
kedorset honnêtement j'en sais rien moi
je ne suis plus dans le détail les
péripéties des gouvernemental en plus la
la question des Affaires étrangères
dépend des numéroos 1 un peu partout pas
des premier ministres comme en France
donc c'est c'est une autre question mais
je crois je peux quand même répondre
plus franchement à la question qui est
que une puissance comme la NRE ne peut
pas se passer d'un d'un corps
professionnel par rapport à ça on peut
pas être le seul pays au monde qui
compte qui n'est plus de voilà donc je
j'entends bien ce qui a été dit par
l'élyée quand il y a eu la réforme sur
l'ouverture les échanges le bon mais
c'est tout à fait atteignable tout en
maintenant une une formation
professionnalisante donc moi je souhaite
que après la création de l'INP après
Elena donc on puisse
reconstituer reconstituer dans les
systèmes des années à venir des filières
où des gens deviennent de grands
diplomate qui se passe pas du jour au
lendemain hein qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour
être un grand diplomate d'apentissage
c'est comme dans la qu'est-ce qu'il faut
pour être un grand diplomate faut avoir
voyagé faut avoir une une copine une
femme d'une autre nationalité il faut
avoir habité dans un autre pays il faut
il faut être ouvert d'esprit il faut
s'intéresser à la culture de l'autre
pour être un bon diom au minimum ouvert
d'esprit il faut fermer sa gueule il
faut fermer sa gueule ça c'est autre
chose c'est l'exercice de la du pouvoir
de la parole ça qu' faut pas faire
bêtement mais il faut en tout cas être
curieux des autres les autres cultures
dans l'idéal maîtriser plusieure langues
des autres si possible avoir voyager bon
il faut tout ça mais en même temps il
faut avoir une idée claire de ce que
l'on
représente du pays que l'on sert après
il faut distinguer les fonctions de de
représentation précisément ambassadeur à
tel ou tel endroit c'est très important
il faut réussir à disons optimiser les
les meilleures relations possibles entre
le pays qu'on présente le pays dans
lequel on est et cetera c'est tout un
travail en choix c'est un vrai métier
hein pensez qu'il ne peuvent pas
apprendre comme ça de gens à l'école ça
apprend avec des maîtres comme dans les
un artisanat au sens le plus noble du
terme il reste des maîtres et il y a le
métier oui lesquel mais non je pas citer
des noms parce que non non on fera la
liste de ceux que j'ai pas cité c'est
ingérable pour moi ça et et d'autre part
il y a le métier de
négociateur c'est très important c'est
pas la même chose il y en a dans les
grands grands diplomates bien sûr dans
les ministres mais il y a des grands
négociateurs à la tête du CAC 40 ou dans
les métiers techniques alors le
négociateur il faut le faire former par
le gignn ça dépend des cas ça dépend sur
quoi vous négociez donc les négociateurs
ils doivent bien savoir ce qu'il
représente alors si c'est une entreprise
c'est une ch si c'est un pays il y a
toute une histoire derrière les naan
surgissent pas comme ça toute une
histoire donc savoir qui on est d'où on
vient quel est l'objectif à long terme
quel est l'objectif immédiat dans telle
ou telle
négociation sur quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
faut obtenir à tout prix ce qu'on peut
faire des
concessions quelles sont celles qu'on
peut pas faire et que pense l'individu
qui est en face l'homme ou la femme qui
est en face de vous pour négocier quelle
est sa vision est-ce qu'il peut concéder
sur un point et C voyez ça c'est le
négociateur c'est pas la même chose
que que donc la personne qui représente
le pays qui doit gérer le rayonnement le
sof power chose comme ça alors si vous
êtes dans des négociations dures en plus
à l'époque de la dictature de la
transparence là je vais pas me faire des
amis parce que les gens adorent la
transparence il faut être transparent
sans arrêt sauf les gens sur leur vie
privée ça leur plaît pas ni sur leur
médecins ni sur leur banquiier ils ont
pas envie que ce soit transparent mais
sur tout ce qui est sur leur maîtresse
aussi sur leur maîtresse oui d'accord
mais en tout cas sur tout ce qui est
public qui veut une transparence totale
ça veut dire en gr qu'il y a plus aucune
négociation possible sur rien parce que
dans toutes les négociations sérieuses à
un moment donné il y a un compromis il
compris dans les cas compliqués que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les cas où il
faut parler avec des g et qui on ait si
possible envie de ne pas parler il y a
des momentsù on n pas le choix voyez on
parlait du Proche Orient imaginez qu'un
processus redémarre
israélien palestinien inallah si c'est
transparent à la première minute c'est
terminé terminé l' princip bon donc a
tout cette mécanique qu'il faut
maîtriser et donc je crois qu'il y aura
des il y aura toujours des grands
négociateurs des grands diplomates mais
dans un livre récent que j'ai coordonné
je conclus qu'il y aura pas l'équivalent
dans l'avenir de taléran mnique et
compagnie parceo le bouquin c'est les
grands diplomates c'est un livre que
j'ai fait avec Benoît Yvert le patron
des éditions Périn c'est lui qui a l'idé
D et on a choisi 20 personnalités on
aurait pu en mettre 30 ou 40 mais on
peut pas faire un livre et on a choisi
des gens qui vont de Mazarin à Lavrov
pas tellement qu'on aime Lavrov mais
c'est pas mal d'avoir un vousz déjà
rencontré je l'ai vu deux trois fois
mais c'est pas la même époque mais en
tout cas on a fait écrire par Sylvie
Berman qui l'a connu à New York au
Conseil de sécurité donc c'est pas un
tableau d'honneur c'est pas les gens
qu'on aime c'est les gens qui ont compté
dans la période des quelques siècles en
question bon il y a 20 auteurs je crois
que ça c'est un livre qui marche
d'ailleurs très très bien et en
conclusion moi j'aiécris la conclusion
en disant dans le monde actuel et de
demain il y aura pas l'équivalent de
Teran ou même de Kissinger Kissinger il
a été au pouvoir 8 ans on peut
d'ailleurs débattre de son bilan on peut
être pour ou contre certaines choses
mais la mise en scène après pendant 50
ans quasiment le travail intellectuel
d'analyse insurpassable mais il y a une
sorte de de mise en scène de showof bon
donc personne d'autre n'aura ce tempslà
dans les temps qui viennent et
d'ailleurs le travail diplomatique au
plus haut niveau est absorbé par les
numéros
depuis l'invention de la télévision et
des sommets comme ça place les
ministères les ministres des Finances
ont de plus en plus d'importance ils ont
ils se voient ils ont des réseaux entre
eux les directeurs du Trésor même chose
des
finances Bruno Le Maire je vous le
rappelle non mais je parle mondialement
et historiquement en général il y a très
peu de mon raisonnement qui sois
franco-français comme je baigne dans
cette ambiance internationale depuis
toujours c'est la ce que me vient de mes
références il compris sur le proch
Orient d'ailleurs Bruno le mer c'est
l'écume des choses comment Bruno Le
Maire c'est l'écume des choses non c'est
un bon ministre même s'il est très très
attaqué là ces jourci en plus il écrit
moi je trouve ça bien beaucoup de gens
disent mais c'est incroyable d'écrire
vous êtes diplomate vous non non je en
plus je suis pas diplomate vous êtes
quoi B je suis j'étais chef de la
diplomatie mais pas diplomate au sens de
l'appartenance à un corps mais ça
m'empêche pas de les défendre mais
j'aime bien les gens qui écrivent et qui
lent en plus bon voilà donc c'est mais
je vaux pas entrer dans le débat de la
conjoncture politique puisque je me
l'interdit en général revenons revenons
à nos moutons quand on est diplomate
français se retrouver au bord d'une
société de cybersécurité ou de
cyberarmement qui lâche dans la nature
euh Pegasus qui se retrouve sur le
téléphone de notre ministre de la
Défense
c'est bien c'est pas bien le devoir de
réserve pas de devoir de réserve j'ai
pas fini nos services de
renseignement ils l'ont laissé aller au
bord pour avoir de l'info où ils étaient
complètement aveugles ils l'ont pas vu
vous voyez de qui je veux
parler un vieil ambassadeur un peu qui
qui qui croit pas à la guerre que
l'Europe est en train de se préparer oui
le chef de la diplomatie européenne dit
que il faut que l'Europe se prépare à la
guerre mais lui il croit pas du tout à
la guerre honnêtement sur l'affaire
Pegasus j'ai pas les éléments pour en
juger faitun diplomate se retrouve au
bord de cette société il doit y avoir
écoutez on a vécu depuis 20 ou 30 ans
dans une idée de mondialisation ouverte
et heureuse de libéralisme très poussé
l'économie est la maîtresse du monde la
diplomatie c'est quelque chose
d'archaïque et à peu près dans tous les
pays développés les les barrières ont sa
in donc ce que vous me décrivez c'est sa
puissance 10 aux États-Unis depuis 50
ans par exemple il faut jamais se
comparer au derniers de la classe oui
mais je veux dire c'est pas un phénomène
je défends pas le le cas le cas en
question j'ai pas d'avis franchement
j'ai pas les éléments par ex il y a une
c'est un des éléments de la la tenstion
france-moc des dernières années péasus
alors qu'en fait tout le monde est déjà
écouté par les agences américaines donc
on se demande où elle a la la proportion
des indignation donc moi je suis plutôt
de formation on va
dire plus classique par rapport à ça
donc si on pouvait restaurer d'une façon
générale dans la fonction publique mais
après après des règles de
déontologie ce qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
fait pas et cetera oui je trouverai ça
plutôt mieux mais je suis pas un juge je
vais pas me proncer sur un cas parle la
Chine sans avoir tous les éléments on
parle de la Chine si vous voulez on
commence par quel bout mais quel est
qu'est-ce que vous avez en tête la la
guerre à taiïwan ou quoi ouais la guerre
à taiïwan ça va être résolu rapidement
non les Taïwanais sont en train de
transférer leur technologie en Arizona
parce qu'ils commencent à avoir peur de
la guerre comment ça va se terminer
cette histoire là les les chinois alors
la Chine il a tellement de chos à dire
d'abord on a beaucoup attaqué les
Allemands parce qu'ils avaient exagéré
dans la dépendance par rapport au gaz
russes he ces dernières années mais je
rappelle que il y a pas si longtemps
quand les Chinois ont commencé à devenir
provocateurs à mordre les molets des
États-Unis Clinton les Américains ont
dit c'est pas grave ils remplissent
aucune des conditions mais on va les
mettre dans l'UMC ça va Leser à se
développer à s'enrichir et donc à
devenir
démocratique donc l'espèce d'incroyable
illusion qu'on critique les Allemands
d'avoir recultivé à ce sujet c'était une
idée général triomphaliste c'est
l'époque on a tellement gagné l'histoire
est finie on a gagné donc on peut faire
ce qu'on veut on peut sanctionner qui on
veut et donc on on a pas peur de la
Chine voz c'est pas vieux ça alors du
coup ça s'est retourné autrement et
quand sin King est arrivé en disant on
est tellement puissant qu'on a plus
besoin de respecter les consignes de
prudence et de
dissimulation que denging nous avait
légué l'Occident et quand même c'est pas
trop sur quel pied danscer en fait parce
que l'Occident globalement ne peut
toujours pas se passer de la relation
avec l'économie chinoise vous voyez les
conséquences récentes sur la crise
immobilière le ralentissement en Chine
tout le monde en a le craint même ceux
qui disent qu'il faut couper les
relations le craign donc a une sorte de
d'imbrication en fait les Américains
sont donc passés de découplés à D
risqués on peut pas s'en passer complèt
bon donc il y a une inquiétude
économique et sans qu'on le dise
ouvertement il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises occidentales qui dépendent
du marché chinois donc elles peuvent pas
à la fois faire un trait sur l'énergie
russe et puis le les marchés chinois
donc il at une contradiction dans
l'Occident après il y a la question
taiïwan qui est venue parce que c'est
une P un ton de plus en plus offensif et
que certains se disaient que si la Chine
ce qui est pas mon pronostic enfin bon
si la Chine voulait faire une opération
sur Taïwan et que les Américains ne
l'empêchaient pas la garantie américaine
ne valait plus rien nulle part al que le
monde est un peu bordélique il y a pas
d'ordre mondial en fait encore moins une
communauté internationale il y a une
sorte d'ordre mondial il a quand même
les SEP flottes américaines et et cetera
donc quoi que pense le président
américain du moment je sais pas quand ça
sera ou bien les Taiwanais il y a C
cette obligation et on voit bien que le
changement de ton chinois amène une
partie des pays de l'azéane qui ont peur
se dire faut mieux s'arranger les
chinois mais d'autres à se dire il faut
resserrer les liens avec les États-Unis
avec le Japon et ce et ceter donc ça
monte mais je ne crois pas que les
Chinois prendront mais je peux me
tromper totalement il y a des ruptures
dans les pronostics des fois je vois pas
les ÉtatsUnis pardon excusez-moi je ne
vois pas les Chinois lancer une
opération en sachant
que les éatunis sont un peu obligés de
les en empêcher faudrait que le régime
chinois soit soit au abois c'est pas le
cas en cherchant des dérivatifs soit
totalement sûr de sa supériorité al
c'est pas la même chose de faire des des
manœuvre
cyber d'occuper des îos de payer des
Gâts à Taiwan et et puis d'attaquer
militairement avec en plus que vous
disiez dans votre question l'enjeu va se
réduire l'enjeu technologique puisque
les usines des chiconducteurs
irremplaçables vont être ailleurs mais
ça ça va dans les deux sens parce que ça
peut conduire à ce que l'Occident dise
après tout on s'en
fiche mais pour que ça ne ruine pas la
crédibilité américaine il faudrait qu'à
un moment donné les Indes de faç son
cynique vraiment cynique pas au sens on
n le terme à Tor et à travers tous les
jours en disant ce n'est plus dans les
intérêts vitaux de l'Occident
débrouillez-vous avec Pékin mais il
faudrait qu'il dis ça des années avant
avant pour que ce soit pas pris comme un
effondrement de la crédibilité
américaine même question on en a parlé
tout à l'heure
sur même constat sur le fait que
les les les Américains peuvent pas
laisser Poutine gagner la bataille en
Ukraine voyez une question de
crédibilité américaine qui est très
largement derrière l'élection de
novembre est-ce
que vous avez un sujet que vous
souhaitez aborder avec nous où est-ce
qu'on passe à l'Amérique du Sud un petit
peu avec l'Argentine ou est-ce qu'on
passe un petit peu sur la géopolitique
de la mer la géopolitique des océans ou
est-ce que vous voulez aborder un sujet
en particulier maintenant non parce que
sur les chets que vous évoquez qui sont
tout à fait
intéressants on va décrire les choses
c'est dire finalement qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire juste avant Sibérie Chine
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez le la
Sibérie et la Chine la Chine va prendre
la Sibérie par la par sa population la
Chine va prendre la Sibérie parce que la
Russie sera affaiblie par l'Europe du
moins le conflit en Ukraine les les
comment ça se passe je pense qu'une
des une des conséquences malheureuses de
l'enchaînement qui aurait pu être évité
Ukraine Russie et compagnie le lien
entre la Russie et la Chine une des
conséquences c'est qu'on crée un
ensemble donc on on donne tout en
prétendant que le sud global n'existe
pas on crée une sorte d'alliance qui est
qui est dangereuse pour nous donc une
vraie réale politique inventive
disruptive stratégique devrait être pas
maintenant on peut pas mais dans
quelques années de couper le lien à
nouveau de refaire ce que Kissinger
avait réussi autrefois entre l'URS et la
Chine voyez mais maintenant sur la
Sibérie je peux dire parce que avec le
recul je peux citer deux trois choses de
Jacques Chirac dont j'étais le ministre
il avait Jospin et Chirac un jour Chirac
me raconte que il avait reçu Deng
Xiaoping au tout début quand Chirac
était Prem ministre de giscar ça nous
mène en en 75
ou 16 il le rechoit et d ne contrôle il
est revenu protégé par sch à un moment
donné il est revenu mais il est pas
encore le maître du jeu il y a encore la
bande des quat et tout ça il va le
maître de la Chine en 78 79 enfin quand
même il est revenu dans le circuit il
parle avec shirac et Shirak lui dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire avec tous
ces chinois tellement nombreux pour les
nourrir et cetera et d lui dit ça se
passe à bmanère le dîner et d lui dit
n'oubliez pas cher ami que la Sibérie
est
vide
bon quelques années plus tard quand je
suis ministre j'ai fréquenté Primakov
qui a été ministre puis Premier ministre
à un moment donné
entreine avait choisi Primakov plutôt
que Poutine la suite a été très
différente Primakov c était un un vieux
crabe
expérimenté très nationaliste dur mais
enfin très très logique très rationnel
très négociation d'accord genre guerre
froide donc ça a été complètement
différent bon en du Primakov je suis
devenu très amis avec lui il a fait un
livre que j'ai préfacé et dans la la
version française bien sûr s'appelle et
je notéis j'ai oublié c'est les mémoires
de Primakov mais j'ai oublié cherch
Primakov mais j'ai pas le titre et je je
notais que dans le livre il était obsédé
par cette question qui est la vôtre en
rappelant à l'époque ça devait être
moins de 20 millions en tout cas moins
de 20 millions d'habitants
entre loural et
Vladivostock bon alors je crois que
c'est dans la tête des
Russes je sais pas si ça se conctrise un
jour je sais pas si les Chinois auront
besoin de revenir à l'ancienne on on est
les plus forts on vous a sauvé
maintenant on va reprendre ce qui est à
nous il y a quand même des des
organismes en Chine des sang qui publie
les cartes dans lesquelles on voit les
TER cétait une erreur ils avaient dit
que c'était une erreur
oui ENF ça existe c'est la Chine cultive
énormément la la l' histoire des traités
inégaux la le siècle des humiliations en
général ça concerne les Anglais les
Français le sac du palais d'été le
président jemine qui m'avait reçu
j'étais ministre simplement mais Chirac
l'avait appelé pour qu'il me reçoive il
m'avait cité Victor Hugo en
français enfin une petite phrase les
barbares c'est nous ce que Victor Hugo
avait écrit à notre sujet concernant la
destruction du palais d'été par rapport
à ça et dans les souvenirs chinois il y
a pas que les occidentaux il y a la
Russie qui a piqué des morceaux entiers
de la ce que la Chine estime être
chinoise donc il a quelques cartes qui
existent c'est habile de les laisser
sortir de dire non on s'est trompé je
suis ça existe bon est-ce que ça viendra
un jour est-ce qu'ils auront besoin de
ça on peut imaginer
que même avec le maintien des frontières
telles qu'elles sont maintenant
inattaqué quoi en fait on peut tout à
fait avoir une présence chin des
investissements des des entreprises où
ils feraient ce qu'ils veulent quoi et
ils trouveraient en Sibérie le le bois
ou les minerais dont ils ont besoin on
n'est pas obligé de passer par des des
changements de frontière à l'ancienne
mais la question que vous avz posé je
pense que plein plein de Russ se la pose
énormément un sujet en particulier on
aborde un sujet de votre
choix mais serait important qu'est-ce
qui vous RA dans les sujets il y a le
monde entier on peut parler de la
géopolitique des poules on peut parler
d'énormément de choses B je vous pose
une question internet non mais je peux
pas prendre lespaule ou les l'Amérique
latine parce que la question c'est qui
fait quoi donc ça nous ramène à quelles
sont les cartes que la France encore ou
l'Europe donc je dise un mot sur
l'Europe ça c'est très important je peux
vous poser une petite question avant de
parler d'Europe oui question internet
que pensent-il du rôle de l'Égypte qui a
refusé d'ouvrir sa frontière au Gazaoui
malgré les efforts de remise de dette
des États-Unis une population est
décimée à sa porte et il refuse d'ouvrir
pourquoi bah le l'Égypte est un pays
fragile
surpeuplé donc ils sont terrorisés en
fait il vient avec l'argent de l'Arabie
ou d'Abu Dhabi et ils veulent qu' le
moins
de le moins de perturbation possible
quoi donc l'idée que il y a énormément
de Gazaoui qui arrivve au Sina
ça les angoisse
énormément même chose sur l'affaire des
outils c'est catastrophique pour eux que
la mer Rouge soit de vie dangereuse
d'accès il peut pas sécuriser le canal
de suè tout seul ni la mer Rouge donc
c'est un pays sur la défensive mais
puisque vous revenez au au Proche Orient
indirectement via l'Égypte ça me permet
de dire quelque chose qui est important
pour moi il y a quelques semaines dans
une émission à propos du livre sur les
grands diplomates j'étais c'était C news
europen j'étais interrogé
sur sur le prochorient entre autres et
j'étais relativement optimiste enfin
j'essayie je sais bien que c'est pas
évident mais donc je parle de ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur la le réveil
d'un camp de la paix et un journaliste
me dit c'est impossible il y a 700000
colons qui se sont installés en
cjordanie et je reprends des arguments
israélien je connais en disant non c'est
pas
700000 c'est plutôt 500000 et dans cela
les les violents sont très peu nombreux
et je dis oui je sais bien ils sont très
violents il y en a qui ont oisonné des
puits ils arrachent des oliviers ils
tièchent sur des gamins qui Vime lancer
des cailloux et cetera c'est quoi vos
sources bah les source c'est des
reportages depuis 20 ans c'est des
reportages d'ONG israélienne de où la
Paix Maintenant ou des arrêes ou des
témoignages même américains il y en est
pas mal dans le Washington Post et
cetera alors évidemment ça a provoqué
une réaction et j'ai été je regrette de
m'être exprimé comme ça parce que ça
pollue un peu le le thème général
c'était de dire c'est pas insurmontable
finement ils sont très peu nombreux en
fait s' a un vrai processus les
arriveront mais j'étais attaqué parce
que l'histoire des puits par qui par
différents organismes qui défendent le
Israël on va dire bon en disant c'est
horrible de dire ça parce que ça renvoie
au au clichés antisémite d'autrefis
l'hire des puits alors c'est vrai que
d'après les informations que j'ai
accumulé depis des années il y a
quelques cas où des jeunes colons
agressifs ont jeté des animaux morts
dans des puits des Palestiniens pour
pour condamner les puits de même qu'il y
en a qui jettent leurs ordures par les
fenêtres tout ça mais bon il y en a il y
en a pas beaucoup ça existit mais en
fait j'en ai j'ai pas besoin de dire ça
pour développer mon risonnement par
contre le l'arrachage des des oliviers
c'est permanent et puis le fait de tirer
sur les gamins c'est tout le temps
regardez le nombre de morts depuis en
6hders je parle pas de Gazin donc je me
suis exprimé alors que je voulais être
plutôt encourageant sur le fait qu'un
processus peut renaître renaître et
malgré moi j'ai j'ai heuré des gens qui
ont dit c'est quand même des clichés
d'avant mais c'est souvent des gens qui
qui sont très sympas qui vivent en
France qui sont pour la solution à deux
États mais qui en réalité ne suivent pas
en détail la situation en Israël et en
cjordanie et le débat en Israël qui est
très très libre comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
donc j'ai dû m'expliquer et plein plein
de mes amis m'ont dit d'accord c'est
peut-être arrivé mais il vaut mieux pas
le dire non il vaut mieux le dire parce
que sinon on alimente l'amalgame si il y
a pas de dans il faut que les gens
arrivent à distinguer la défense
d'Israël absolu sur sa sécurité son
droit d'exister et le comportement de
tel ou tel courant politique qui en plus
sont très différents j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure la différence énorme entre la
séquence Rabine et cetera et la séquence
netaniaho donc c'est je suis content
d'avoir l'occasion de de préciser ça et
les informations que j'ai que j'ai eu
depuis en parlant avec mes amis
israéliennes c'està dire que réellement
s'il y avait un
processus on verra finalement les les
gens tellement violents qu' seraient
prêt à s'opposer par la force à au
changement de statut de la sjordanie
sont quand même très peu nombreux
quelques milliers l'immense majorité des
des colons c'est des jeunes couples qui
vivent le long de la ligne verte du HLM
par rapport à ça donc c'est pas le sujet
donc ça nous renvoie est-ce qu'il y aura
à nouveau en Israël des des gens
courageux qui diront faut régler la
question de fond qui est une question
politique est-ce qu' trouve en face deux
des bargouti ou autres les gens pour
jouer le jeu c'est ça le vrai sujet en
fait indépendamment de la la violence
qui existe mais qui est finalement très
limité un mot sur
Nordstream qui a
pété d'après ce que j'ai lu c'est les
Ukrainiens ça paraît logique mais j'ai
pas d'information spéciale jeis pas
grenouille non plus donc mais ça serait
pas euh ça serait pas impossible on
parle d'Europe alors sur l'Europe c'est
un mot valise hein comme disaient les
linguistes donc moi je sais ce que sont
les Européens un finlandais un Grec un
portugais mais l'Europe est-ce qu'on
parle de la
Commission du Parlement d'Ursula de la
Cour de Justice de la campagne d'Ursula
oui qui sa campagne on ne peut la
comprendre que si on comprend qu'elle
veut plaire au Parlement européen elle
veut pas plaire aux Américains plutôt
non c'est d'abord le
Parlement là n'empêche pas l'autre enfin
bon en tout cas quand vous dites Europe
est-ce que ce sont les institutions
européennes qui sont d'ailleurs pas en
ligne entre elles est ce sont les 27
gouvernements presque tous de Miss
est-ce que c'est l'Europe future élargie
à 30 35 ou est-ce que c'est l'idée que
chacun se fait de l'Europe donc
finalement la définition n'est pas
claire et donc il y a le il y a le
l'affrontement qui est depuis l'origine
de la construction européenne
entre ceux qui se disent c'est
l'approche pragmatique l'union fait la
force donc si on est regroupé sur des
sujets centraux et ben on va peser plus
par rapport à notre Ali américain ou par
rapport à la Russie ou par rapport à la
Chine et Cera et cetera et ceux qui ont
une une pensée philosophiquement
fédéraliste et qui mett en avant le fait
que nous les Européens on a un passé
chargé alors ça c'est tout le débat
colonisation le passé qui passe pas tout
ça on a on s'est quand même laissé
complètement intoxiqué par les névroses
américaines sur le sujet alors que c'est
un sujet assez différent c'est prière
chose de dire on a un passé chargé donc
nous les état nation d'Europe qui sommes
la source de tous les mots on va va
transférer nos pouvoirs à la commission
qui va devenir le gouvernement de
l'Europe et il y aune petite partie des
élites qui joue cette carte donc je
crois que les européistes qui sont ce
que je viens de définir là tout à fait
sincère d'ailleurs tout à fait mais ils
ont creusé le
fossé avec les peuples et moi je me suis
rendu moi j'étais un pro-européen
centre-gauche classique on va dire très
à l'aise avec la politique de miteran
mitteran col de l'or et cetera mais
quand il y a eu le traité de Maastricht
absolument logique parce que la France
avait déjà décroché avant économiquement
maintenant c'est plus grave mais déjà
avant et quand il fallait dévaluer parce
qu'on a pas le choix pour relancer les
nos exportations et quand il fallait
sortir des 5 % autorisé par le système
du du SM du serpom smme il fallait
supplier le gouvernement de la banque
centrale allemande allemande avant donc
devenir quelque chose dans la monnaie
unique c'était plutôt mieux en fait même
en terme souverainiste même en terme
nationaliste raisonnable bon traité de
Maastricht al miemp en plus elle a voulu
ratifier par le référendum pour le
sanctuariser sinon ça aurait été remis
en cause alors nous autour on était un
peu naïf on lui avait dit formidable
vous faites un coup génial parce que
vous êtes sûr que ça va passer à 80 %
tout ça et il nous avveit dit dès le
début
détrompez-vous on on doit faire ça je je
dois faire ça mais ça passera ricraque
et si on fait une bonne
campagne bon la campagne démarre la chè
ballon l'Europe c'est la paix l'avenir
la jeunesse tatata bon et tous ceux qui
sont contre sont des crétins archaïque
sou et progressivement le le oui
baisse jusqu'à ce que pendant j'étais
secrétaire général à l'époque jusqu'à ce
que Jacques Pilan pendant l'été qui
était le conseiller mais pas comme au
sens banal d' aujourd'hui vraiment
penseur stratégique comme tout ça il me
dit il faut trouver autre chose parce
que les arguments classiques
fonctionnent plus du tout plus du tout
et on commence à réfléchir à une autre
argumentation alors on étudie tous les
sondages qui existe et on voit qu'il y a
un besoin de
protection je vous parle de 92
92 parle pas de 2024 92 besoin de
protection mais disons les les militants
fer av l'idée européenne n'acceptait pas
cette idée il s'agit pas de protéger il
s'agit de faire rayonner nos valeurs
vous savez les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres bon pour protéger Chun doit être
ouvert à tout le monde donc il a une
bataille interne une bataille interne
sur l'expression que finalement myan il
a compris le danger il a vu et dans le
débat avec cein ou sein d'ailleurs
honnêtement a dit des tas de choses paix
à son âme mais intelligente mit été plus
fort que lui enfin sein n'a pas dit de
bêtises c'est
intéressant Philippe sin disait des des
choses extraordinaire sur le budget de
la France oui on peut dire ça alors donc
mit a dit une Europe forte nous
protègera mieux nous protègera mieux je
suis pas loin de penser que sans cette
phrase ça passait pas c'est passé un
point d'écart un point d'écart donc dans
mon histoire
personnelle tout le monde s fiche mais
c'est pour vous expliquer ma position
d'aujourd'hui le fait que un traité
soutenu par tout le monde sauf
Jean-Marie Le Pen à l'époque qui avait
beaucoup moins de poids que sa fille
aujourd'hui ça passe AC un point d'écart
là je me suis dit il y a il y a un bug
quand même on a perdu les peuples en
route donc l'Europe risque de devenir
une locomotive sans wagon qui fait que
mon obsession depuis intellectuellement
et politiquement c'est de retrouver un
deal entre les élites pro-européenne et
les peuples donc ça veut
dire accepter de préserver la
souveraineté qu'on a gardé arrêter de
faire de souverainisme une injure il
faut vraiment être
complètement je sais pas où enfin dans
une bulle pour ne pas comprendre que les
gens sont attachés à la souveraineté ils
nont jamais eu dans l'histoire les
peuples il la conquère par la démocratie
ou la République mais on va vous le
reprendre absurde ça n'aurait jamais dû
être dit ça bon donc il faut la calmer
et c'est normal que les gens soient
attachés à la soué si on peut démontrer
qu'on peut ajouter à ça mais pas
soustraire une souveraineté européenne
très bien en plus si on peut démontrer
qu'il y a un contenu par rapport à ça
donc moi je sais pour une pause depuis
longtemps et qu'on arrête de dire sans
aronstruction parce que ça donne le
tourn à la fin faut bien s'arrêter quoi
voilà donc j'approche la situation
actuelle à travers de ce long
raisonnement historique en estimant que
même si on a été obligé pour des raisons
morales de faire la promesse à l'Ukraine
de l'adhésion qui est réalisable pour le
moment mais du coup on est obligé de
s'occuper des 10 pays qui attendent
depuis très longtemps pourquoi
irréalisable pour le moment vous parlez
comme Antony blinken maintenant ben j'ai
souvent parlé comme lui d'ailleurs ce
qu'il dit sur le prochain r para tout
sur l'Ukraine je suis assez d'accord
avec ce qu' dit enfin sur ce point
précis on sait bien la Russie ne
tolérera jamais que l'raine rentre dans
l' temp du moins l' on parlait de de
l'Union là pardon oui il a il y a
l'Union il y a l'ut temp c'est différent
mais l'élargissement de l'Union on l'a
promis moralement pour les aider mais
ils remplissent aucune des conditions
bon à la limite on peut imaginer s'il y
avait un statu quo qui est pas génial
comme solution mais que une partie
rentrerait après tout on a accepté
Chypre il y a de tiers de Chypre bon
pourquoi pas bon et après il y a tous
les pays qui attendent déjà et si on
veut pas les déstabiliser avec toutes
les influences les manœuvres turque
saoudiennes islamistes chinoise et
compagnie il faut créer quelque chose
avec ce cet ensemble Macron a eu tout à
fait raison là-dessus de réveiller la
vieille idée de miton Confédération qui
est une idée géniale qu'il a lui-même
tué dans l'œuf on la lançant beaucoup
trop tôt quand tous les médias disaient
que c'est un vieux crabe qui comprenait
rien eu même n'avait rien compris il
était hyper en avance et le point faible
c'est que pour aider gorbatcheev il
avait mis l'URS parce qu'il pensait que
c'était dans notre intérêt bon il aurait
dit Confédération qui a un partenariat
avec la Russie on va discuter c'était
différent bon c'est une occasion manqué
mais il y a il y a de 3 ans les Italiens
enricoa Dragui et Macron qui l'a repris
ont lancé la communauté politique
européenne dont personne se préoccupe
pour le moment mais dont je pense moi
qu'elle peut devenir le rendez-vous de
tous les Européens o il aurit tous les
Européens même la Bretagne et que les
Européens bon on verra on verra je sais
pas si ça va marcher en tout cas c un
cadre tout à fait propice alors que dans
l'affaire d'actualité vrai
élargissement je pense qu'il faut
résister à l'idée que comme on va devoir
élargir à toute vitesse il faut faire
des réformes énormes donc changer les
traités généraliser le vote à la
majorité que demandent les Allemands
depuis toujours c'est dans leur texte
mais c'est parce que aussi ils ne
peuvent pas être mis en minorité donc il
y a un problème pour la France donc je
serai pour qu'on se calme làdessus que
on gère les élargissements le mieux
possible il y a une très bonne idée de
bourlange il y a quelques semaines qui
dit on peut pas raisonner plein adhésion
ou bien au contraire les pays restent
dehors il faut qu'il a une approche
progressive sur des années au fur et à
mesure de le développement et qui
participe à des programmes à des
programmes à des projets ceci cela donc
ça se gère sur 10 15 ans TR ça beaucoup
plus malin que le choix impossible
d'autant qu'après quand un pays est
devient membre il faut le ratifier et il
faut l'accord des 27 ou des 30 32 35
donc on s'est lancé à la fois dans un un
mélange de d'usine à gage et d'impasse
donc je serai moi pour calmer les choses
de dire qu'il y aura il y a pas de
nécessité de réforme des traités qu'on
fait une pause sur la la réglementation
qui est toujours exagérée et que
l'Europe va fonctionner par grand projet
il y en a plein il y en a plein le vrai
problème beaucoup plus grave que ce dont
on a parlé c'est le compte arbourg
écologique ça c'est la la l'avenir non
pas de la planète si dans un siècle il y
a la planète qui avec des fourmis c'est
pas c'est pas bon pour nous donc
l'avenir de la vie sur la planète tout
le monde est en train de se rendre
compte plus ou moins même s' y a des
freinages énormes c'est une course de
vitesse entre la dégradation des
conditions de vie et ce que j'appelle
les
écologisation de tout de tout par étape
bon l'Europe c'est pas que l'Europe bien
sûr et c'est pas que les institutions
c'est les entreprises les chercheurs les
inventeurs les gens mais dans la
bataille mondiale là-dessus on voit bien
le l'Europe reformuler des grands
projets où il y a l'écologie l'économie
la technologie la science et personne va
être contre les gens vont débattre sur
le rythme les modalités l'accompagnement
mais personne peut être contre alors
quand on prend les sujets
souveraineté défense tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué voilà donc je
prends la question européenne pas du
tout à travers l'actualité pas du tout à
partir des élections européennes dont on
connaît en gros le résultat c'est quoi
c'est par là qui passe en France non
mais je parle globalement ah pardon bah
il est en tête largement pour le moment
on verra mais on sait que le parlementen
sera un peu plus à droite quoi
globalement vous expliquez que Bardel et
soit en tête comme ça bah je pense qu'il
y a il y a la stratégie de Marine Le Pen
qui ne dit rien et qui n'a pas de
position précise sur quoi que ce soit et
donc elle est pas attaquable alors que
dans les démocraties modernes on les on
détruit les gens qui prennent des
décisions sur quoi que ce soit et puis
un sentiment qui se répand qui est que
on a tout essayé mais pas ça pourquoi
pas bon c'est quand même usant hein et
puis les la dénonciation classique
du contre le le pénis n'a pas bien
fonctionné déonation morale on va dire
depuis très longtemps c'est la qu'est-ce
que vous entendez la dénonciation
classique c'estàd l'
l'ostratisation le fait que à chaque
fois qu'il sortent dans les médias et
pendant 15 minutes il se fassent
tabasser dessus et et qu'ensuite ça les
fait monter plus qu'autre chose c'est
quoi ben c'est ça c'est ce que vous avez
dit mais c'est l'idée générale depuis
très longtemps et de la gauche d'une
grande partie en tout cas les
chiraquiens de dire on va dire qu'on
combat le retour du fascisme qu résumet
les années 30 les idées a abonde les
amenis noir tout ça bon cétait employé
contre Jean-Marie Le Pen ça jamais bien
marché d'ailleurs quand ça côte les les
gens n'ont pas intégré que les gens
détestent les élites c'est injuste enfin
bon des fois c'est légitime des fois
c'est légitime enfin globalement c'est
absurde mais c'est comme ça c'est un
fait politique donc quand les quand les
gLite tape sur quelqu'un la sympathie du
grand public va à celui sur lequel on
tape Jean-Marie qui était un sacré
roublard là-dessus quand il baissait
trop il vient une déclaration
provoquante donc tout le monde hurlait
c'est atroce c'est ané noir tout ça bon
il remonta après donc il fallait sortir
de ce piège parce qu'en réalité ils
n'auront de solution à rien sur les
sujets d'aujourd'hui il fallait
développer ce qu'avait dit fabus il y a
très très longtemps les électeurs leurs
électeurs posent des vraies questions
mais le fondational apporte de mauvaises
réponses bon mais la la gauche n'a pas
exploité cette voilà donc donc je je dis
ça tout ça pour dire que ça n'a pas
marché que si ça avait marché
l'ustracisation Marine Le Pen serait à
15 c'est pas 40 donc je pense qu'il faut
approcher les les choses autrement et
que en réalité c'est il nont pas de
solution ils sont le
sous-produit d'une négation d'une
incurie et du nontaitement des flux
migratoires qui sont traitbles on en a
parlé tout à l'heure si on apprend
l'approche Scand nave
voilà l'élargissement de l'OTAN
l'Ukraine qui s'élargit dans l'OTAN
c'est une provocation une ligne rouge du
wish full sinking mais les Américains
sont contre non il y a blinken qui a dit
qu'in fin l'utant du moins l'Ukraine
rentreré dans l'ut temp un jour oui un
jour un jour et ça c'est dans
l'hypothèse où les le conflit s'est
finalement arrêté on a réinventé un ce
genre de déclaration ce genre de
déclaration quand il y a russe en
face c'est de la provocation c'est un
manque de sociop perception par rapport
au
rus les r sont pas idiots ils savent
très bien aussi qu'il a une ils sont pas
IDI mais il sont un peu têtus quand même
non oui mais ils sont contre ils sont
ils sont contre ah oui ils sont contre
ils sont contre absolument mais
l'Amérique ne peut pas dire ils rentront
jamais donc blinen non blinken s'en sort
plutôt bien la de Biden blinon plutôt
bonne par rapport à ça alors
paradoxalement moi qui étais convaincu
par le plan brginski il y a très
longtemps descennies 90 il faut pas
mettre l'Ukraine dans l'OT temp faut
faire un statut de finlandisation et
cetera et cetera au point où on était
arrivé quand il y a eu le sommet de
Bucharest en
2008 je crois avec des accords
là-dessus avec la ligne américaine
disant il faut les mettre dans l'OTAN et
Sarkozy et Merkel
on dit non alors le compromis même moi
ce que je pense que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure je pense que le résultat était
le pire de tous parce qu'en gros le CH a
dit ils ont vocation à entrer dans le
temps mais pas tout de
suite donc le message à Poutine c'est
dépêchez-vous c'est un message absurde
quelle que soit la position parce que
soit il fallait dire et bien on les met
dans le temps et c'est comme ça on avait
la trè guerre mondiale dans la journée
non s que non
à l'époque surtout à l'époque l'époque
où Poutine était plus maléable mais non
il fallit mettre dans le temps disant on
va les mettre dans le temps mais il y
aura un statut spécial pour la Crimée et
et la la Russie gardera éternellement
sébastopo BL bla fallait monter un truc
fallait négocier à à la Kissinger comme
les les grands grands grands
négociateurs mais on les met dans le
temps il n'aurait pas osé prendre le
risque ou alors fallait dire ils n'ont
pas vocation dans le temps ni
aujourd'hui ni demain mais pour que la
Russie n'en profite pas il fallait bâtir
retrouver le plan brginski de quelques
années avant et le bâtir à ce moment-là
mais je bornis à dire ils ont vooccation
mais pas tout de suite et n rien faire
après c'est la pire position à mon avis
est-ce que est-ce que le l'Europe peut
résister à une guerre
froide tel que vous l'avez connu
c'està-dire un rideau de fer
total est-ce que l'Europe peut survivre
à ça au 21e siècle bah elle a déjà
survécu non comment bah la guerre froide
s'est terminé par la la désagrégation de
l'URS mais pourquoi ah ça c'est autre
chose mais est-ce qu'elle peut résister
oui monieur oui économiquement parlant
mais c'est infiniment dommage c'est
dommage culturellement
intellectuellement historiquement de se
remutiler à une époque où par rapport au
défi du pseudo Sud global même s'ils
sont hétéroclites entre eux et cetera et
cetera il n'empêche que la Russie même
si c'est une histoire un peu spéciale
quand même TR siècles sous les Mongoles
c'est très particulier mais en fait
quand même il y a une Russie d'Europe on
va dire qui qui fait partie de cet
ensemble donc c'est quand même hyper
hyper dommage d'avoir à son privé et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire que je
trouve quand même
lamentable que même dans l'horreur de la
guerre en Ukraine où l'Ukraine le peuple
ukrainien souffre attrossement enfin
c'est c'est lamentable de la part de
Poutine toutes ces décisions il
n'empêche que les gens qui disent B non
on va arrêter de de lire de soyesski ENF
c'est effrayant et on va arrêter les
expositions de char russe mais voilà
mais c'est effrayant c'est effrayant il
faut complètement dissocier les deux il
y a évidemment en Russie d'abord on
évalue à 1 et demi ou on sait pas 2
millions de Russes entre guillemets
modernes enfin qui qui sont désespéré
par la guerre quen fich leamp dans plein
d'autres endroits il y en a plein
partout il y a un attachement il y a
forcément des Russes qui même avec la
propagande disons un peu parano tout le
monde veut nous détruire et compagnie
bon il y a quand même des tas de Russes
qui sont pas à l'aise avec ça puis de
toute façon ça n'a pas de rapport pas de
rapport donc moi je suis complètement
opposé au au boycotte de la culture
russe mais ça nous donne pas la disons
la martingale pour retrouver une
relation avec la Russie maintenant
maintenant il faut au minimum que
la que la guerre s'arrête au
minimum qui est très loin des de bandes
ukrainienes est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que la poutine il accélère
en Ukraine pour conquérir un maximum de
territoire pour pouvoir ensuite négocier
et dire ok on vous rend un oblast mais
on garde le donbas la Crimée hop
l'Ukraine neutre et ça suffit non
Poutine pour le moment il essaie
d'avancer en Ukraine il grignote un peu
et il attend
Trump mais je redis comme je l'ai déjà
dit que je n'imagine pas qu'il puisse
dans cette année même si c'est entre
Biden et Trump il y aura peut-être
encore Biden après on sait pas qui
toucha au système
otanien donc là où il y a un risque
d'opération pour grossir la position
russe dans une éventuelle négociation
c'est dans des pays de cette zone qui
seraiit pas couvert par par
l'OTAN est-ce qu'on parle d'un autre
sujet le
est-ce que vous voulez dire un mot
dessus
oh pourquoi pas mais si je dis un mot ce
serait pour dire que c'est une énorme
bataille
mémorielle qui dure
depuis pas d' pas le génocide et la
prise de pouvoir par Kagamé de 94 que
moi j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs comme
ministre quand j'étais ministre je l'ai
rencontré en 2001 et 2002 pour parler du
Congo déjà dans l'Est du Congo mais à
partir du depuis le rapport d' musciio
qui était un ancien ministre ou juge de
Kagamé qui se protégeait à travers ça
des l'enquête du jug Brugière dans
l'affaire de l'avion donc dans la pormux
il y a une série d'attaques qui pour
faire diversion en fait contre la France
qui à mon avis sont infondé à 100 % et
la bataille a lieu sans arrêt depuis il
y a rien de neuf en dépit de la disons
que on était
submergé c'est étonnant d'ailleurs que
les médias français c'est relé disons à
95 % la la thèse de la culpabilité
française c'est un phénomène quasiment
ethnographique étrange parce qu'on en
est à 30 ou 40 livres dans le monde
entier beaucoup de livres d'Africains
d'Américains de journalistes beaucoup de
femmes d'ailleurs canadiennes Belg et
cetera qui étudie soit les l'origine
l'histoire des mass en 62 où les TS ont
été massacrés au moment du départ des
Belges le départ des touts exilés en
Ouganda la Constitution après sous
l'égite d'un chef remplacé ensuite par
Kagamé des tsis en Ouganda qui veulent
revenir chez eux il y a plein de livres
là-dessus la décision de Kagamé de
déclencher la la guerre en en 90 qui est
le début de de l'engrenage et puis les
années 90 11 12 13 là où il y a le moins
de livre d'ailleurs c'est sur les les
accords d' chat l'été 93 c'est dommage
parce que l'engagement de la France
contrairement à ce qu'on a entendu 1000
fois 90 a permis les accords d' rouchin
un compromis qui à l'époque avait été
considéré comme un un énorme succès et
Jup avait il y a pas que la France qui a
joué un rôle les Africains et cetera
mais si la France n'ait pas bloqué la la
France de mi-terran puis miterran
baladure Jupé et cetera n'avit pas
bloqué la les attaques il y aurait pas
eu de compromis compromis d'aroucha ça
c'est l'été 93 après quoi la France s'en
va elle est plus là elle est plus là et
en
94 quand le génocide commencec B la du
et mitéran se mettre d'accord en disant
on est disponible si le Conseil de
sécurité vote une résolution on est prêt
à revenir et il a fallu attendre 2 mois
pour que les Américains votent la
résolution tellement ils avaient peur
d'être obligé d'y aller alors qu'il dans
une opération Somalie quelques mois
avant ils avaient perdu 30
marines qui fait que dans le la
communication qu'on n pas bien compris
ces derniers jours de éisienne qui a pas
été confirmé mais quand même il y a eu
des textes sur l'idée que la France et
ses
alliés ses alliés je sais plus quelle la
suite de la phrase ça concerne aussi
africains n'avit pas voulu
arrêter ce qui est incompréhensible dans
ce commentaire sur lequel se sont rués
beaucoup de beaucoup de d'émissions
c'est que le seul pays au monde le seul
qui a tenté d'arrêter qui s'est dit
disponible pour arrêter qui a été
ralenti par l'Amérique le seul pays auqu
on peut rien reprocher c'est la France
al je ne comprends pas
le que les auteurs des livres nombreux
que j'ai cité soient quasiment jamais
invités en France il y a pas que des
auteurs de livres il y a il y a aussi le
prix Nobel de la paix moueg le Congolais
tous les dirigeants congolais bien sûr
est ce que pensent les Ougandais c'est
l'Afrique du Sud il un f assz étrange où
il y a sur ce sujet il y a plus du tout
du tout plus pluralité de pluralisme
donc j'espère qu'un jour on va
rééquilibrer les les analyses parce que
avoir voulu
dire que la communauté internationale
comme dit d'ailleurs Kagamé lui-même
maintenant ce qui est moins pire que ce
qu' disait avant n'a pas voulu ça ça met
pas en cause la France parce qu'elle
était disponible ça met en cause les
États-Unis donc Clinton et Albright qui
ont attendu jusqu'à fin juin pour voter
la résolution pourquoi ils ont entendu
les Belges qui ont retiré les
contingents de la force des Nations
Unies qui avaiit remplacé la France qui
était parti donc ils l'ont retiré parce
que 10 malheureux gars ont été
assassinés avec la première ministre
donc ça met en cause les belge l'enu qui
a rapatrié la minuire tout de suite
kofiana
nibutrosgali et l'ensemble des chefs
d'État africains qui n'ont rien fait
sauf le Sénégal qui finalement quand
l'enu a enfin voté la résolution qui a
permis de faire turquoise qui est une
opération nation génie qui a pas une
opération française il y a eu je crois
un/art des seld qui était sénégalais bon
ce que je viens de résumer en en 3 4
minutes c'est connu depuis 20 ans mais
ça ne passe jamais jamais dans le débat
français donc je pense qu'un jour il
faudra qu'un toute une équipe
d'historiens étudie le génocicide qui
est une atrocité malheureusement est
bien connu he mais la la controverse qui
est je crois sans précédent en fait
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on ouvre nos
archives ben on est les seuls à l'avoir
fait d'ailleurs le président Macron
quand il avait été à à Kigali il a fait
un
discours un peu en même temps voyez il
che che chez nous la veille il y avait
la la notion de responsabilité lourde et
accablante qu'on trouve dans la
conclusion la conclusion du rapport
Ducler qui est lui-même contesté par
unond de spécialiste mais rédigé çon du
claire lui-même c'est pas dans le
rapport dans les 1000 PES du rapport non
mais il avait équilibré à sa façon hein
en demandant notamment que les autres
pays ouvrent leurs
archives ce que aucun n'a fait bien sûr
si la Belgique a dû le faire mais par
exemple l' Randa l'a jamais fait voyez
voilà donc je suis moitié Deré par ce
déséquilibrees mais qui durera pas
éternellement parce que la euh les
Français peuvent pas continuer à dire
quelque chose qui est le contraire de ce
que disent les les grands journaux
anglo-saxons michelang qui est une
canadienne qui a fait un livre récent
elle a eu des des Grands Prix aux
États-Unis en censé pas le Washington
Post donc le je crois pas qu'il puisse y
avoir une vision franco-française
uniquement à charge et isolé de tout le
reste voilà bon on verra question
Internet est-ce que monsieur vidrine a
lu le dernier livre d'Emmanuel Tod le
déclin de l'Occident si c'est le cas
qu'en pense-t-il VO là là je lis
toujours c'est toujours intéressant il y
a tout un débat sur l'Occident il y a
Colosimo qui prend le sujet dans l'autre
sens c'est-à-dire la pourquoi la haine
de l'Occident bon on peut pas empêcher
le fait que les Européens d'abord et les
Occidentaux après et réussi et coloniser
les tr/4 du monde bon comment ils ont
réussi ça c'est un sujet d'ailleurs les
pays du Sud ferait bien de se demander
s'ils avaient le culot pourquoi ils
étaient colonisables parce qu'il
tireraient des conclusions très utiles
pour eux pour gérer les Chinois par
exemple choses comme ça ça dépend des
pays en fait il il y a pas que les
supériorités technologique qui avait été
donné aux Européens par la révolution
industrielle alors donc c'est un énorme
sujet le vrai passé qui passe pas on
nous a rabutu les oreilles c'est
celui-là en fait c'est les qu ou 5
siècles passés après ça prend d'état de
forme parce que il y a des pays du Sud
enfin le sud je met toujours les
guillemets on voit pas puisqu'on parle
mais des pays du Sud qui disent euh on
va prendre notre revanche bon pourquoi
pas c'est votre tour allez-y les gars
allez-y mais d'autres veulent se
venger les Chinois veulent se venger non
ils veulent
rétablir une sorte de suprématie et
disons l' Milon ça veut rien dire il y a
pas de monde global donc ça veut rien
dire les statistiques sur l' 1000 on
s'en fiche mais en tout cas c'est pas
les mêmes les pays qui ont tout raté ils
ont besoin de se venger ils ont besoin
de Bou émissire on parlait tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs des gouvernements les
incapable de quelques pays du Sahel
après il y a une énorme différence d'un
pays à l'autre la gestion de ces
questions historiques n'est pas du la
même de la part de l'Algérie ou du Maroc
par exemple voyez il y a plein
d'exemples comme ça donc alors il y a un
énorme débat alors après une fois qu'on
a compris ou pas compris les raisons de
la mise en cause de l'Occident et qu'on
a réfléchi à la façon de répondre à ça
il y a aussi l'approche to on peut dire
l'Occident va quand même
rebondir parce que c'est quand même la
les sociétés les modes de vie les
meilleurs qu'on a jamais vu vous y
croyez ça oui oui il suffit de comparer
mais je distingue entre la rhtorique des
dirigeants du Sud qui ont besoin d'un
discours postoccidental et les classes
moyennes de tous ces pays des milliards
de gens qui veulent vivre à
l'occidental en terme de liberté en
terme de de vie pour les femmes en terme
technologique c'est comme l'Europe qui a
fabriqué la révolution industrielle mais
donc faut pas mélanger les deux vous
pouvez voir des pays où les gens ne
rêvent que de ça d'importer chez eux les
modes de vie éventuellement d'allit
faire des études bien raconté par des
une romancière extraordinaire du Nigéria
cette cette contradiction par rapport à
ça et le discours des dirigeants c'est
tout à fait autre chose donc après il y
a tout un autre débat qui est Politi
diplomatique qu'est-ce que l'Occident
doit faire par rapport à ça donc le
livre d'autonne fait partie des choses
qu'il faut lire pour réfléchir sur la la
gestion et moi je pense qu'il faut
déglobaliser le sud global et qu'il faut
pas le le légitimer le crédibiliser le
stimuler le renforcer par une sorte de
discours occidental qui à la fois arneux
et paniqué il faut faut s'y prendre
autrement faudrait dire euh on pas faire
de la diplomatie en 3 minutes là mais il
faudrait dire jeis global je sais même
pas ce que c'est mais on a des
avec la Chine l'Indonésie l'Inde le
Brésil et cetera et
cetera question internet euh est-ce que
vous avez déjà lu Charles on on c'est
mal écrit Onana
ou Anana
ou no Onana Onana Onana c'est un c'est
un auteur un des auteurs de livre euh
sur la laaffire rouandaise qui qui est
très combattu par les les partisans de
la narration Kagamé que j'ai croisé une
fois dans un colloque au Sénat qui avait
été organisé par Gérard Longuet Alain
Richard où je me suis exprimé en disant
que je trouvais courageux les gens qui
contestaient l'idée que la France soit
coupable de tout mais non pas que
j'adhère à tout le leur thèse et tout le
contenu des livres que que j'ai pas lu
en général mais il fait partie des des
auteurs africains mais les les
Sud-Africains sont moins connus mais ils
ont un peu les mêmes les mêmes positions
que le je CIS Onana Charles Onana
Charles Onana pourquoi la Suisse et
l'Autriche ne sont pas dans
l'UTAN bah ce qu'ils veulent pas
j'imagine bah la Suisse elle tient comme
la prudelle de ses yeux à sa neutralité
en fait donc là il y a un débat interne
mais quand même quand même et l'autrich
je sais pas où on est l'opinon
autrichienne là-dessus
mais tous ces pays qui ont été neutres
pendant longtemps euh c'est compliqué
d'abandonner ça quand même regardez les
pays alors les pays de de Scandinavie
s'en sentaient plus plus menacés comme
la Suède par exemple sur ça qui sont
d'ailleurs obligés de dire il faut
vraiment entrer dans le temps parce que
Poutine va nous envahir la semaine
prochaine bon il simplifi un peu ils
exagère un peu mais c'est pour àagère
même complètement mais ils en ont besoin
par rapport à leur opinion mais il reste
des relicat de d'ailleurs ça nous amène
très très loin les questions c'est
intéressant parce que si est élu ce qui
est pas sûr sil est élu et qui met en
œuvre ses positions ce qui est pas sûr
non plus il est pas exclu que en Europe
si Trump nous dit maintenant
débrouillez-vous entre vous ce soit pas
évident de d'élaborer une ligne commune
sur comment les européens peuvent se
défendre par eux-mêmes il est pas exclu
qu'il a des pays qui disent moi je veux
pas rentrer dans l'usine à gaz d'une
défense européenne je redeviens neutre
bon ça dépend de comment ça ça se passe
ça dépend si c'est préparé ou pas et
j'imagine que les dirigeants actuels en
Europe de façon j'espère la plus secrète
possible réfléchissent déjà à la
l'hypothèse Trump quand
Emmanuel Macron discutait avec Poutine
et que derrière ça a été filmé et
ensuite diffusé dans un documentaire ça
se fait ça se fait pas c'était une
erreur c'était une grossière erreur
c'est certainement une erreur puisque ça
a été relevé contre lui si ça avait été
relevé que pour lui ça n'aurait pas été
une erreur donc il a pas il y a pas une
définition à priori voyez c'est une
question d'opportunité de contexte c'est
une er de puceau diplomatique non
j'entre pas dans ce détail là encore une
fois je suis Macron est un détail non
c'est pas du tout un détail mais je suis
professionnellement compréhensif je sais
que c'est très très très compliqué voilà
mais je ne critique pas le fait que à
l'origine le président Macron a voulu
tenter de rétablir une une discussion
avec Poutine utile je peux pas le
critiquer cont tenu du fait que je
regrette que l'Occident n'ait pas été
plus réaliste dans la décennie 90 mais
on voit avec le recul que ça n servit à
rien et que c'était trop tard en fait
mais je trouve pas ça intellectuellement
condamnable c'est pas scandaleux
contrairement à ce qu'écrivent toute une
série de de gens aujourd'hui qui veulent
raconter que les européens se sont
trompés depuis le début ils ont été
fascinés par Poutine et ça bon les
Européens vont trop loin ils sont la
plupart des Américains sont pas sur
cette ligne donc je vois très bien que
l'opération Macron Poutin n'a pas marché
en fait mais bon je vais pas lui jeter
la pierre là-dessus question internet
encore une dernière question encore deux
dernières questions il y aura une
question de G et une question de bnash
qui est en train d'écrire donc la
question de G quel est la quel est le
scénario probable qui pourrait mener à
l'éclatement de l'Union
européenne a priori il y en a pas parce
que tant que l'Europe n'a pas de
compéten en matière de défense elle n'en
a pas les traités ne donnent pas une
compétence dans ce domaine elle peut
avoir éventuell une compétence en
matière de production d'armement ou
d'industrie d'armement c'est du domaine
actuel de breton mais le reste le marché
commun tel qu'il est devenu les
interdépendances l'imbrication c'est
tellement fort le brexit a tellement mal
tourné que je vois pas les autres
européens sortir si le brexit avait une
réussite flamboyante il y aurait une
dizaine de pays qui auraient dire bah
moi aussi je vais sortir mais c'est pas
le cas donc je vois pas la sauf si
l'Europe donit une réforme des traités
qui à mon avis n'aura pas lieu mais
imaginons si l'Europe devenait une
entité géopolitique et stratégique elle
serait exposée au problèmees des
puissances en vrai avec des plus
d'éclatement sur des sujets hyper hyper
compliqués comme la Russie la Chine le
Proche Orient mais vu ce que l'Europe
actuelle ce qu'elle va rester je crois
pas de
Villepin président de la France vous y
croyez pourquoi il est candidat non je
l'ai vu récemment il m'a pas dit ça en
fait il veut pas il m'a pas donné
l'impression de vouloir se se relancer
dans le le mél mélo politique est-ce que
vousz à mon avis il a pas fini de faire
des propositions et de d'avoir des idées
on va on va le recevoir ici est-ce que
vous avez trois livres à cons à notre
communauté et est-ce qu'il y a un
bouquin que vous avez écrit qui pourrait
être intéressant pour notre
communauté alors j'en cite un je sais
pas du si c'est intéressant mais c'est
le dernier comment il s'appelle Albert
Camu notre rempart il est paru il y a
quelques jours personne l'a lu encore
mais et vous ne l'avez même pas emmené
dédicacé c'est vous l'avez là c'est une
non c'est une passion d'adolescence
auquel je reviens avec le temps qui a
passé ma vie dans pouvoir j'essaie de
par ce que c'est une passion et jeve cet
homme merveilleux encore plus
merveilleux on a tout relu de lui et sur
lui donc ça c'est récent Camu notre
rempard s'il faut un sous-titre c'est
rempard contre l'imbécilité et le
fanatisme bon ça c'est Camu euh ensuite
alors un livre qui se rapproche plus de
notre entretien c'est un livre que j'ai
coordonné sur les grands diplomates les
grands diplomates de la période très
large Mazarin lavrof Lavrov Lavrov
et donc il a il y a tan il y a metnique
a Kissinger mais il a des gens moins
connus comme William pit ou kit et on a
intérêt nous les Français à regarder les
autres et je trouve ça honnêtement c'est
une idée de
l'éditeur de de Périn qui est Benoît
Hivert mais j'ai coordonné j'ai pas j'ai
pas rédigé les les les 20 biographies je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant au-delà
de l'histoire moi je suis passionné par
l'histoire mais même les gens pas
passionnés par l'histoire je leur dis
que vous voyez bien qu'on n'est pas
encore dans la communauté internationale
c'est trop chaleureux ça serait sympa
mais c'est pas le cas bon on n'est pas
non plus revenu dans la guerre froide
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué est
westmond c'est plus compliqué donc c'est
pas inutile c'est pas son intérêt de
regarder comment les les maîtres pas les
numéro 1 pas les rois mais les grands
ministres comment ils ont géré les
rapports de force en essayant de les
équilibrer quand est-ce que ça a marché
quand estce ça pas marché donc je pense
qu'il y a un intérêt pratique utilitaire
à lire ce livre sur les grands
diplomates et permet-moi de rappeler que
j'ai fait il y a 3 ans aussi un un
dictionnaire amoureux de la géopolitique
pu celià il est assez connu donc c'est
pas la peine que le voilà euh deux
livres que vous avez pas écrit mais qui
peuvent être intéressants qui ont compté
pour votre vie il y a 18000 personnes il
y a 18000 personnes en direct sur
Twitter et sur Youtube on est à peu près
4000 oui mais il y a tellement de livres
j'ai lu toute ma vie moi depuis que je
sais lire des milliers de livres puis ça
dépend des moments si vous aviez un
livre à conseiller à votre petit-fils ah
bah lui il a il a 16 ans et demi il est
passionné d'histoire il est passionné de
bataille de bataille de bataille il
connaît le déroulement de 5 je sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs de 5 ans de bataille
surous l'Empire romain il connait très
bien la les guerres civiles des Romains
il connaî très bien la la bataille dans
les euh en en Allemagne Auguste dit mais
qu'as-tu fait de mlions qui ont été
anéantis par les Germains enfin c'est
incroyable donc il faudrait que je lui
conseille des choses qui euh sont un peu
différentes d' il y a 2 jours avec moi
il a acheté un livre sur Dianne
biannefou comme qui un garçon de 16 ans
et demi tout ça bon voilà donc lui je
lui suggère plutôt de lire Balzac et
prou en plus mais les livres à citer
c'est trop difficile ça dépend des
moments dans moi j'ai des passions euh
Camu euh biaac euh malerau château
brillant ENF ça dépend des moments en
fait qu'est-ce que vous lisez en ce
moment en ce moment
j'ai je lis le procèpétin proc Pétin de
de l'auteur anglais là qui qui a fait
uneère biographie de de De Gaulle qui
est extraordinaire je lis ça et je relis
pas je relis je lis un livre de Jean Gau
exceptionnel que j'avais jamais lu sur
le désastre de pas vie la bataille où
François prer a était fait a était fait
prisonnier alors vous savez que Jeau
était contesté pour ses position ça nous
a coûté encore un bras cette histoire
pourquoi on a pas été obligé de verser
une rançon non le on n pas été obligé de
verser une rançon je me trompe ah bah il
a été fait prisonnier par charlequin ah
oui exact il a é obligé au bout d'un
moment de c'est effrayant d'accepter que
ses fils le remplacent de petits gamins
enfin ils vont survivre quand même après
mais Jeau était attaqué estce qu'il
était
pacifiste très pacifiste quand même très
bon pas du tout net pendant la guerre
immense écrivain à part ça alors du coup
après la guerre il s'est lancé dans un
un réi de bataille quoi pour montrer
qu'il était très à l'aise dans les
choses militaires et de bataille et
c'est une des descriptions en dehors des
très grands films il y en a sur
waterloot ou autres une description
extraordinaire de la bataille la
bataille qui est une ESP c'est
totalement chaotique c'est monstrueux et
c'est bon mais c'est magnifique ce livre
qui est très ancien mais je lis beaucoup
de livres d'avant parce que toute la
littérature contemporaine notamment les
romans j'attends au moins un an que les
choses soient décomées est-ce que vous
avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose
d'impérissable les jeunes générations tu
quel âge bah celles qui vont venir faire
la guerre contre les Russes et les
Chinois et bien je leur dis fermez votre
écran tout de suite et prenez un livre
n'importe lequel Hubert Vedrine merci
merci pour votre
[Musique]
invitation